Keep
waiting, huh?
Oh!
Oh my god, I don't know what it is.
This, like, title, menu, music is making me so emotional.
Takizo!
Thanks to the vibe, Captain!
And...
Oh no, am I gonna say your name wrong?
Joao!
Thanks for the tag, Captain!
Welcome home, boss!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Can we watch the one hour briefing too?
Oh yes.
First of all, yes.
I'm still free.
Thanks for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
I shouldn't thank you for the 10 gift.
Thank you guys.
I want to...
Before we start, I want to kind of...
I guess go over some stuff.
Because I think maybe some people are like...
Maybe some people are like...
I think Mint has played Metal Gear before, so...
What's the deal, yo?
Is she just playing... replaying Metal Gear?
Essentially!
The short answer is yes.
The short answer is just yes.
I'm replaying Metal Gear series.
So...
But probably for like the games, like when I played Metal
Gear Solid originally, I played like the original
PlayStation version.
This time I will be playing Integral.
So probably for games like for the games, I'll probably be
playing them like maybe like a different version of them.
Um, thank you guys for all the gifted.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Integral has Japanese text only for the for the menus.
Um, everything else is in English.
So don't worry if you're just like, wait, but it's in
Japanese.
Only like the stuff about the weapons and, you know, the
information about like the ration.
Stuff like that.
That's only... But we know what the guns do.
We know what the Nikita missiles do and the Stinger missiles
do.
Yeah, so it will be in Japanese, but all the voices are in
English and everything like that.
So gun goes pew pew.
Oh my gosh, thank you, sent to it.
Wow, thank you so much for that.
Akasupa, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Is it EN dub?
Yes.
It is still EN dub.
Yes, yes, yes.
Huey voice, um, excuse me, boss, the sneaky suit is in the
thumbnail.
Oh gosh, the sneaky suit is in the thumbnail.
Um, but, uh, essentially, I really love Metal Gear, and I
just really want to stream it.
Um, I think I've, oh my gosh, Kaleopar, thank you for the
birthday gifted!
Thank you guys for all the gifted, thank you so much,
Bloodless.
Thank you for the 10 Gifted.
Did you know that you can put fake data on the virtual
memory card for these versions?
I did know that!
I did, I did, I did.
But thank you for the reminder.
I really just wanted to play Metal Gear.
That's why, well, I played Twin Snakes.
There's actually one Metal Gear game I still haven't played,
which is Acid, so...
But also, I need to get through the other games to get to
Acid.
um oh and ghost babble you're so right and ghost babble but
um but anyway um uh so when i think of like my channel and
like the games that i've played like i think of it kind of
as like a resume where i'm just like this is this is my work
right it's kind of like you know how do I say it like if
someone were to be like what what has mint played what does
mint like it's kind of in that way I'm like oh yeah I can't
claim to say that I love metal gear so much and not have it
on my channel you know what I mean yeah like a portfolio
yeah that's a better way to say it that's that's the word I
was thinking of a portfolio and so if you're just like you
know I think Mint has already played Metal Gear I think she
really likes it but I also need people who don't know me who
come to my channel for the first time to also see how much I
love Metal Gear aka Konami Konami if you're watching hi I
love Metal Gear please sponsor me thank you I'm waiting for
Delta I'm very patient but also snake is running out of air
and is little again.
Thank you, Ducky.
Thank you for the dono.
But also, even though my brain rot for Metal Gear is very
great, I am not a gamer.
So please, be patient with me.
There may be times that you say, mint mint.
Do this thing instead.
What's wrong with you?
And my brain says no.
So, please be patient with me.
Because I'm not a gamer.
And I will mess up and be slow.
Please be patient.
I'm a V-Tuber.
You may say things such as, V-Tuber!
Get the thermal goggles!
And I say, no!
stubborn but we're just here to have a good time um i'm not
doing any sort of challenges or anything like that i'm not
here to be like european extreme no kill no alerts um
whatever whatever i'm just here to have a good time and
relish in my brain right will you play vr mission someday i
would love to because i've actually played um like not vr
missions the game the game but like some of of the VR
missions, but I do know about, like, the fun, the fun, oh my
gosh, hi, it's me, thank you for the 50 gift, you guys are
going so crazy, thank you so much, thank you, um, um, what
was I saying, oh, like, the fun missions, like, the one
with, like, the giant, um, genome soldier, and the one, my
favorite is the, um, is the locked room murder mystery, love
it, love it, love it, love it, Jinola, yeah!
The return of Jinola.
But yes.
So, yeah, we're just here to have a good time.
I really love Metal Gear.
I really love, you know, I love the gameplay of Metal Gear,
but I mostly love the story.
So if you're just like, God, she loves Metal Gear so much,
but she's so bad, it's because I'm a sucker for the lore.
That's okay.
I endure the gaming and the stealth so that I can see the
characters that I love so much
But anyway, so if you're just like man what games will mint
be playing of Metal Gear?
Probably all of them Because I want them on my channel and
also I like them And yes, I think that includes five because
I'm insane
Oh, God.
So, I think this will be a pretty long journey of Metal Gear
Madness.
But I think we will have a fun time.
So, let's start.
First, a Metal Gear Solid Integral.
I'm gonna be playing them as if they are, uh, as if, like,
not that I'm playing for the first time, but if someone has
never seen Metal Gear before, I'm not gonna be like, um, I'm
going to try to avoid spoilers when talking, and also I'm
going to, uh, watch, like, all the cutscenes and things like
that, as if we're playing it for the first time.
Um, so if anybody also has never experienced experience
Metal Gear, and it's your first time watching, you can feel
like this is a safe place.
Well, hopefully.
Gosh, oh my gosh, thank you for the magic.
Thank you guys for the super chats and all the giftings.
I really, really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Should we do smiley faces in the chat?
You can do it if you see a spoiler, but don't do it for my
sake, because, you know, for me, it's whatever.
But you can do it if you're just like, hey, get that spoiler
off the screen.
for the new people.
Hmm.
Yeah.
So hopefully we can all respect that and remember that for
future games as well.
And, you know, it's not going to be.
If you forget, that's okay too.
Don't worry about it.
I'm new.
Are you?
Oh yeah.
You're totally new.
I've never seen your name before.
Sorry.
The dog's in.
Oh, doki-dokki.
Thanks, guys.
Let's do the edit save data first.
Okay, it did save.
I did test it out earlier, so...
Well, I guess spoilers, I guess.
Oh, wait.
Back.
Cool.
Start the main...
Oh, my gosh.
You guys want to know what I love so much about...
Look at this.
So...
wait how do i go through it ah no how do i move through it
how do i jump to page no oh there we go i was like what the
hell guys look at this when i okay so someone's making a mod
that puts my me that puts me mint phantom into the game you
can play it's a mod it's a mod swap and i was just like, oh
my gosh, what if I, like, dub over Snake's lines so that,
you know, so you like Tokimeki Memorial.
Oh my gosh, yes.
And, like, I was like, what if I dub over this, all the
lines?
And I was, like, totally serious because I was like, um, the
Master Collection has the entire script.
Oh, the game.
And also...
of the codex.
So I was like, it'll be easy.
So I hope you guys are excited for membership dubbing
streams for the next couple of months.
I'll probably do it in membership, so yeah.
And then I will just be recording for days.
Who the hell is Kenneth?
Kenneth!
Kenneth Baker, I forgot this is...
I always...
I thought...
Just seeing Kenneth not Baker by itself?
Like, Kenneth by itself is just so funny.
Oh, spoilers!
Oh my gosh, there's spoilers here, you guys.
Open the menu.
How do I get out of here?
Oh, yes.
Yes.
Kenneth Baker Kenneth is just such a funny like oh it's
Kenneth anyway okay you guys we'll see him later actually
the MGS 2 sneaking suit is just the suit from MGS 1 with the
vest and pants swapped out for tactical harness so close
enough to be oh thank you yeah I'm just I'm in the thumbnail
I'm just a little more naked but not naked snake unless oh
my gosh you guys i think i manifested i think i manifested
the the um the mgs2 figma redo like or update because like
literally the day before i was on my ps3 getting ready for
tokyo jungle and i was like oh i wonder if they still have
like the icons and can buy a Metal Gear icon.
And you know which one I bought?
I bought Metal Gear Solid 2 Snake icon!
I almost bought Paz.
I almost bought Peace Walker Paz, but I was like, no.
You know what?
I really like the blue.
I really like the Metal Gear Solid 2 blue.
Now I'm going to get Snake.
I think I manifested it.
I think I did that.
You're welcome, everybody.
That must be why they released it.
I think so.
Will your MGS mod have the cake?
Of course.
Actually, I think you should ask the people, the modelers.
If it isn't saucy, mean.
Ah, I'm late.
No, you're not.
We're just getting started.
Don't worry about it.
Oh, my gosh.
Here we go, everybody.
Choo, choo, choo, choo, choo, choo.
Choo, choo, choo, choo, choo.
Choo, choo.
Choo, choo, choo.
Have you ever played Police Knots?
Not yet.
I do know what that little tune is from Police Knots,
though, right?
Or was it Snatcher?
It's one of them.
I can't remember.
Hi, Menzo.
Oh!
Ah!
Uh...
Hold on.
Wait.
Was it an...
No.
No, uh, ah, hold on, ah, uh, ah, hold on, ah, wait, no, not
off, ah, whoa, ah, hold on, uh, return to the menu.
Wait, uh, wait, how do I do it again?
Oh, shoot, um, ah, ah, I forgot to change it to the, oh,
it's under, okay, we have to go to the main menu, we have to
go to the main menu in the game, and change it there.
My bad, sorry, I forgot to change it to the subtitles, I
forgot to change the subtitles.
it's because we just went straight into the video there we
go there we go there we go there we go there we go it's just
because we went straight into the game right so i was like i
was like wait i didn't change it okay we'll just we'll just
watch the briefing okay now now we got it okay now we got it
Thank you.
It's been a long time, Snake.
I should have known you were behind this, Colonel.
That's no way to greet an old war buddy, Snake.
What do you want from me?
I just invited you here so we could have a talk.
Invited?
That's what you call sending armed soldiers after me?
Who's taking care of the dogs?
Sorry if they were a little rough with you.
But we've got a serious situation here.
get us out of it i'm retired from foxhound you're not my
commander anymore and i don't have to take orders from you
or anyone else like a high definition you will take these
orders of this without the filter and everything of this
picture excuse me who's this dr naomi hunter she's chief of
foxhound's medical doctor naomi hunter therapy are you
military how's the audio by the way
That's why a lot of people think he was blonde.
This injection won't hurt a bit.
Oh, no.
What's the shot for?
It's hurting me.
You don't like shots?
No, I don't.
Snake, listen up.
It all went down five hours ago.
Heavily armed soldiers occupied Shadow Moses Island.
Shadow Moses Island?
On Moat Island off the coast of Alaska.
Alaska?
What soldiers?
Next generation special forces led by members of Unit
Foxhound.
Foxhound?
They've presented Washington with a single demand, and they
say that if it isn't met, they'll launch a nuclear weapon.
Uh-oh.
A nuclear weapon?
I'm afraid so.
Makes me real happy to see a play.
You see, the island is the site of a secret nuclear weapons
disposal facility.
Foxhound hijacking a nuclear weapon?
Now you understand how serious the situation is.
Foxhound?
You'll have two mission objectives.
The DARPA chief, Donald Anderson.
The diaper chief.
And the president of Arms Tech, Kenneth Baker.
Kenneth!
They're both being held as hostages.
Those are some heavy-duty hostages.
Secondly, you're to investigate whether or not the
terrorists have the ability to launch a nuclear strike.
And stop them if they do.
I think they're bluffing.
Any questions, Snake?
Questions?
Questions.
I haven't even said whether I'd accept this mission.
Well, you can make up your mind.
after you hear more about the situation.
He's like, gosh darn it, President, this isn't what you
promised.
Yippee!
Oh wow.
Well, we can't read it, but that's okay.
We'll just pretend.
Tell me about the nuclear weapon disposal facility.
The disposal facility includes a hardened underground base.
Even with our most advanced intelligence gathering equipment
we can't tell what's happening inside so someone needs to
penetrate gather intelligence and report back sounds like a
spy movie what's the insertion method well an air insertion
is impossible nobody respond a storm going on we'll approach
the disposal facility by sub approach yes within a few miles
of it why is he so surprised that house are you gonna get
there our detection you have to approach the place to get
there thank you engine or propeller noise and then we'll
launch a one-man stv launch same as a torpedo only this has
no propulsion device of its own after the stv gets as close
as it can dispose of it from there on you have to swim you
want me to swim in sub-zero Alaskan water I thought in the
one I thought you could move presents the latest advances in
polythermal technology I thought you could like move the In
this angle, I thought you could move it around, but it's not
happening.
I'll instruct you by codec after you reach your target.
Thank you for the victory, Tango.
As usual, this is a one-man infiltration mission.
Weapons and equipment, OSP.
OSP!
This is a top-secret black op.
Don't expect any official support.
There's so much...
So much technical speak.
Don't expect any support.
This is madness!
Time, Uri-mito.
I can read that.
We have a Taimuri Mito!
No way.
Uh-oh.
What's the time limit?
24 hours.
They say they'll launch after 24 hours.
It's too soon.
Do they say what the target will be?
So far, they haven't mentioned the target.
When did the countdown start?
Five hours ago.
So I have 19 hours.
Oh my god.
Now we're on two.
Roy Campbell, Dr. Naomi.
Oh, gosh.
I give up.
I can, like, read them individually.
But I can't, almost, not all of them.
But, but together I don't know what the pronunciation, the
pronunciation, the reading is it all.
Oh, oh, I can read, oh, camera free!
Here we go.
Woo!
Toes?
No.
Colonel, who are you speaking for?
Naturally, I'm representing the US government.
Too low?
Sorry.
So who's in supervisory control of this operation?
The President of the United States.
Which means that the President must be meeting with his top
aides in the Map Room about now, huh?
No.
At this point, they're still video conferencing with each
other.
Toes!
If that's a real nuclear warhead, shouldn't they issue a
COG?
Not yet.
The Secretary of Defense has operational control and is
fully aware of the situation.
After you infiltrate, if you determine...
and they possess nuclear launch capabilities a cog will be
issued well if they haven't relocated to the nuclear shelter
under mount washington feet free i suppose there isn't that
much reason to worry why don't they give him the national
security agency in on this yes so is the di a snake not
wearing clothes i don't know the di did they did they
capture him did they like kidnap him while he was taking a
bath i just don't understand we need death jockeys we need a
nuclear has already been assigned to us.
What is that?
What's Konamint?
No,
he lives like that.
We need backup from a specialist.
Camera free!
I'm just an amateur when it comes to nuclear weapons.
I know.
That's why I've requested the assistance of a military
analyst named Nostasha Romanenko.
Nostasha!
She'll be providing you backup by coaching.
A female analyst?
She's built up an impressive record as an advisor for the
nuclear emergency search team.
After losing her parents who participated in the cleanup at
Chernobyl, she must have been yours.
I've been watching a lot of stuff about Chernobyl recently.
Where's she working from?
It's like one of those morbid, fast and morbid curiosity
sort of things.
Seems like a million miles away.
Snake taking a bath.
FBI, open up.
A female.
why?
What about Chernobyl?
I don't know.
Just, just like I said, like morbid curiosity.
Those things are kind of, those things are sort of
fascinating, right?
I don't know.
Like, I don't know.
The HBO show is really good.
I think I watched like a little bit of it.
Minto, I know little about MGS lore.
Never finished watching a tiny person's playthrough of it,
but I can assume that AI summary of the chat is an accurate
source of the lore.
Honestly, I can never see what the ai is is saying so i have
no idea oh my gosh i can't wait for the ai summary and mgs
too i'm just living core thank you so much for the 50 gift
thank you but yeah the ai summaries don't show up for me so
um but they're always so funny i love it so much roy camber
says you're zooming in on snake's toes you're retired why
are you involved in this Because there aren't many people
who know Foxhound as well as I do is that really the only
reason I've been soldiering for a long time I don't know
anything else.
I don't know anything else Even though I'm getting a little
old.
I still love to be in the field.
Colonel sounds so like So tell me the real.
I don't know.
Look at this Sometimes he sounds normal and then sometimes
sorry he sounds so like be Frank.
Oh Frank Frank Campbell His niece.
Meryl.
You know, I almost named my cat Meryl.
I was deciding between Meryl and pies.
Señor!
Thank you for the ten.
Gracias.
Meridu!
What was your niece doing here?
Several soldiers were reported missing the day of the
revolt.
And my niece was one of those called in as an emergency.
Oh my gosh, you read you.
Go have fun.
She looks like you.
She's my little brother's girl.
He died in the Gulf War.
And since then, I've been watching after her.
No real combat experience.
The cycle therapy!
I'm retired.
I'm just an old man now.
And I'm your friend.
Yeah, yeah.
Since when are we friends?
Yeah, but that's where we've been friends.
Since the fall of Zanzibar.
Zanzibar.
With my personality, I don't have too many friends.
That's what I trust about you.
It's what makes you human.
Please, Snake, save my niece, Meryl.
Zoom in, dramatic zoom in.
All right.
Who's camera?
But I have two conditions.
Who's the cameraman?
Name them.
How's your cat doing?
No more secrets between us.
I want complete disclosure at all times.
And two, I'll only accept orders directly from you, Colonel.
Yeah.
No cutoffs involved, okay?
Yeah, I only trust you, Colonel.
Agreed.
That's why I was called.
But one thing...
What?
I'm not a colonel anymore.
I love this part.
Just a retired old warhorse.
I understand.
Colonel.
AHHHHH!
No!
What?
It's so sweet.
So cute.
It's a good line.
It really is.
Alright.
Dr. Naomi.
Naomi.
That doctor.
is she part of this operation too she was in charge of
foxhound's gene therapy she knows more about those men than
anyone else you mean you've seen them naked make no mistake
I'm not a nurse I'm a scientist why is that the first thing
you think so you've seen them naked it's a combination of
nanomachines and an anti-freezing peptide so that your blood
and other body fluids don't freeze even at sub-octic
temperatures nanomachines not just one kind either there are
different types which will replenish the supply of
adrenaline nutrition and sugar in your bloodstream oh now I
don't have to worry about food I wish I could get
nanomachines for streaming say what say what tropics a class
of drugs which will help improve your mental functioning
gosh I really need me smarter huh I need these for stream
yes benzidrine it's a type of stimulant it'll keep you alert
and responsive for 12 straight hours yippee I need these for
stream anything else in there there's The nanomachines will
also keep your Codex batteries charged up.
I guess I can call you when I'm ready to go on a diet.
You're welcome.
Click it again and refresh chat.
We'll refresh the chat.
But I don't know if it works on the back end is what I mean.
Yeah, it doesn't work in the back end of, since I look at
chat from like outside of the front spacing.
But thanks for trying.
Okay.
Mile three.
Oh boy, we got all the stuff about the terrorists.
Their demands, the people.
The chief of DARPA and the president of an arms
manufacturing company.
What business did they have at a nuclear weapons disposal
facility?
The truth is that secret exercise will be conducted at the
time the terrorist group attacked.
Must be extremely important exercises if those two were
directly involved.
Were they testing some kind of new advanced weapon?
to that information do we know exactly where they're being
held my i need to find the dapa chief has also been injected
with a mini transmitter as you get closer you should be able
to pick up his location on your radar oh yeah on our on our
little radar why do you know that it's it's so funny because
when i studied in japan recently that was like one of the
kanji that they that was one of the um words that we learned
like I was like, wow, cool.
Hostage.
You would think that I would already know that because of,
like, Detective Conan or something.
I have nanomachines, but you can have gamer subs now with a
10% discount if you put in the code boomer!
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Shameless plug got, though.
Do they really have the ability to launch a nuclear missile?
They say they do.
They even gave us the serial number of the warhead they plan
to use.
What's the number confirmed?
I'm afraid so.
At the very least, they've got their hands on a real nuclear
warhead.
Oh my god, oh, camera free!
Isn't there some kind of safety device to prevent this type
of terrorism?
Yes, every missile and warhead in our arsenal is equipped
with a PAL, which uses a discrete detonation code.
PAL!
Permissive Action Link.
The safety control system built into all nuclear weapons
systems.
but even so we can't rest easy why not because the DARPA
chief knows the detonation code but even if they have a
nuclear warhead it must have been removed from its missile
all the missiles on these disposal sites are supposed to be
dismantled he doesn't i can't imagine snake always dying his
hair right and also that used to be true but since the end
of the cold war you can get anything if you have enough
money and the right connections It looks blonde, but I can't
be.
I think it's just the lighting and, like, the sepia.
Oh my gosh, wait, I just noticed in the background.
You have Kenneth, you have the diaper chief.
You have big boss down here, right next to see it right
there.
But what is that next to him?
Who is that?
And then you have Foxhound and you have Liquid right there
on the right.
Who is that next to big boss?
Hello, boss.
Why are you transparent now?
Transparent?
I am a ghost.
Maybe I'm running out of energy.
Like how Mint repeats back some of the lines as
half-questioned?
Is it the genome soldiers next to him?
No, I don't- I can't tell.
I can't tell.
He doesn't dye his hair.
It's just always full of mud.
Ew!
No, Foxhound is right here.
On the right.
But I mean to the left, like, to the left of the big boss
portrait.
I can't tell.
There's, like, two little, two little people standing.
I can't tell what that is, though.
Hmm.
Oh, well.
It's just Foxhound members.
Um, it's not anyone specific.
How well armed are these terrorists?
I know there was an exercise going on at the time they
were...
revolted.
They're heavily armed, I'm afraid.
What about their battle experience?
And they're heavily stupid.
The six members of Foxhound in charge are all hardened
veterans.
They're tough enough to eat nails and ask for seconds.
I wouldn't expect anything less from Foxhound.
The others are next generation special forces.
They're not your average grunts either.
Oh my god.
They're special guys.
They have a really, wait, don't tell me.
If he tells me that they have a really high IQ, I think
We're in trouble I think we're in trouble if he tells us
that they have a really high.
So what exactly are they demanding?
Persons remains remains remains.
That's right to be more accurate Cell specimens which
contain the individual's genomic information cell specimens.
Why would they want that?
Yeah, that's a terrorist need them.
They need they want to consume them Generation special
forces have been strengthened through gene therapy You've
heard of the Human Genome Project.
Oh, my God.
They've been mapping the human genome, and they're nearly
finished.
They're going to create a whole person.
The military has been working towards identifying those
genes, which are responsible for making effective soldiers.
There are genes that do that?
And using gene therapy, they're able to transplant those
genes into regular soldiers.
Gene therapy.
Gene therapy?
I'll explain this part.
Oh, great.
therapy can remove those genes which we know may lead to
sickness or disease and at the same time splice in genes
with beneficial effects such as resistance to cancer for
example in other words we can overcome all sorts of genetic
diseases and at the same time add genetic characteristics as
desired okay and so if you knew what genes were responsible
for making the perfect soldier You could implant them in the
same way, right?
No, I love Naomi.
Yes, we could.
But it all depends on being able to isolate and identify
those soldier genes.
And in order to do that, it's helpful if you can study the
genomic information of one of the greatest soldiers ever.
Ever.
I'm so glad we get British Naomi back.
For people who don't know, in the Twin Snakes, which is kind
of like a remake of this game, they took away her accent.
Levi or Wrangler?
Like jeans?
Oh.
It took me saying jeans.
Also, ViviCorps, why'd you change your profile picture?
Casual Naomi Hater.
I can't recognize when you guys change your profile
pictures, okay?
Jeans.
What kind of Levi Tommy?
Oh, we got the Tommy jeans in here, too.
Oh, my gosh.
I got, like, the cutest...
Before I couldn't go outside in Japan, I got the cutest
jeans set in Japan.
I'm so happy.
I, like, love wearing it out.
But I feel like...
I feel, like, a little too flashy when I wear it.
I don't know.
Jeans are, like, so popular.
They're the popular...
They're the hit thing, the in thing now.
I used to never own a pair of jeans.
Now I own jeans.
Oh, my God.
One of the greatest soldiers ever?
The man they call the greatest warrior of the 20th century.
You don't mean big boss.
Big boss?
That's right.
We've been working feverishly to identify the genes
responsible for his incredible combat skill.
So far we've discovered about 60 of the so-called soldier
genes.
So his body was recovered after all.
We set that guy on fire.
His cells are remain frozen in a cryo chamber.
It's just like Disney.
His genomic information is a priceless treasure to mankind.
Priceless to the military, perhaps.
but it was possible to restore his DNA profile from just a
single strand of his hair.
Do you think Big Boss's head would be...
And then you're going to transplant those genes into
soldiers?
We'll use a process that I discovered called gene targeting.
Those little head containers like the Futurama.
The strongest soldiers don't become what they are by
acquiring their skills through training or experience.
We now know that hereditary factors are far more crucial for
creating superior soldiers.
Snake, we can't give them his body.
nuclear warheads on that island put together.
I'm going to get his body back.
I hear the terrorists are calling themselves the sons of big
boss.
The sons of big boss.
Oh my god.
I just made a reference that nobody here will know at all.
Okay, so a lot...
Okay, hold on.
Okay, so a long time ago, I found this movie that was like a
knockoff of the Beverly Hills Chihuahua, which I've never
seen that movie before.
But the only reason I bought this movie was because the
Chihuahua png that they used was the same on the front as
the like it was the same on the back as it was on the front
just flipped for some reason that was so funny to me and in
the trailer of the movie the girl the lady is just like as a
chihuahua she's like i'm gonna get my body back and then she
says it again but she's like i'm gonna get my body back so i
would i would quote it a lot and when they were like they
have to retrieve the body i'm like i'm gonna get my body bag
i'm just i'm so sorry i made a reference that like literally
only me and my like me and like a handful of friends would
quote i'm so sorry thanks for the mintsplaining big boss
name of the movie please i can't remember it i can't
remember it there was some chihuahua movie though not
obscure mint reference.
Oh my gosh, thank you for sharing your meme.
Yes, it is my meme.
It wasn't Beverly Hills Chihuahua.
It was one of...
You know how like movies will make like a...
Like a...
Like a knockoff version of like...
You know, they'll make like a knockoff animated version of
Finding Nemo, but it's not...
Finding Nemo, you know?
Things like that.
It was just a...
Oh my gosh.
If I find it, Beverly Hills, Fua-Wawa.
Chua-Wawa the movie!
I think that's what it was.
Chua-Wawa-Wa the movie.
Yes.
And the dog is so ugly.
That they use on the cover.
But she's like, I'm going to get my body back.
I'm going to get my body back.
It's Chihuahua, the movie.
That's what it's called.
Show us the PNG.
Oh, I can show you guys.
You're right.
Chihuahua, the movie.
Okay, hold on.
Sorry, everybody.
It has 3.9 out of 10 stars on IMDb.
So this dog is, I'm sorry to this little...
This Chihuahua has done nothing.
Oh, my bad.
But I think he's just, he just looks AI generated to me for
some reason.
But this is an older movie.
Like, it's not AI generated at all.
It's back when, like, Chihuahua movies were so popular, so
they made it.
Okay, so here's the cover.
And then here's the...
Oh, it's so tiny.
Here's the back.
It's the same dog.
Just flipped.
But he just looks a little uncanny, right?
Like there's just something about him that just doesn't look
right.
I don't know what it is.
Um...
But yeah, hold on, maybe one second.
Okay.
Anyway.
Okay, next thing.
This dog's laying in a few new tricks.
I found the refugee.
Did I remember it correctly or did I just gaslight myself?
My purpose was to respond to threats involving next
generation weapons.
of mass destruction.
It's a thinking she says it.
Including NBC weapons.
Until they were added, that is.
They?
Who's they?
These guys didn't start out as regular army.
Looks like a pretty international group.
Mercenaries.
And it gets worse.
Most of them were from a merchant agency that I think you're
familiar with.
Oh?
They were part of Big Boss's private guard.
And after Big Boss went down, the military just bought out
all their contracts.
Running man's back!
After that, they were merged with our own VR unit, Force 21,
and retrained.
If you ask me, these so-called next-generation special
forces should be called simulated soldiers.
They have no real battle experience.
Video game players, huh?
Oh.
Don't forget they've all been strengthened with gene
therapy.
They carry genes which make them excellent soldiers.
They don't have a high IQ, right?
Don't get careless just because they don't have much
experience.
Yeah.
soldiers was prohibited by international law you would think
yes but those are just declarations not actual treaties the
interesting thing is that nearly every member of the unit
conspired make genetically modified soldiers okay will you
sign this treaty about it no i promise okay i just that
seems like a maddie a maddie comic Or it's just like, you
see, like, the president.
What's the president in this game?
I can't remember.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, no.
Of course I know what the president is in this game.
I'm so silly.
Well, you see George Sears, and they're like, he's, like, at
a little convention.
And they're just like, will you make genetically modified
soldiers?
And he's like, no.
But his fingers are, like, crossed behind his back.
And he's just like, hey.
I imagine the face, um...
What's the face?
What's that comic where the guy's like standing outside the
window and he's like, this guy's disgusting.
I can see this in Maddie's style so clearly.
I know, right?
Yeah, the sickos!
The sickos!
I imagine like that kind of face he makes when he's just
like, I've got my fingers crossed.
Something, something, something, no to you.
Zen means something, something, something.
How could an entire unit be subverted to rebellion?
They're calling it a revolution.
A revolution?
Since they all went through the same gene therapy, they
probably felt closer than brothers.
They see the unit as their only family.
The son's a big boss.
Genetically engineered idle girls.
But if they were regular army, they must have been
interviewed periodically by army counselors.
According to their files, they all got straight A's on their
psychological tests.
They all seemed like fine, upstanding guys.
Patriotic soldiers.
Straight A's.
But they all took part in the uprising.
No.
Several people didn't show up on the day of the exercise.
That's why there was a resupply of troops.
Was there any sign recently that something might be wrong?
There was a report a month ago that they were acting
strangely.
Apparently they consulted classified information about the
soldier genes and performed their own gene therapy
experiments.
They can do that even without you?
Well, our gene therapy process is almost completely
automated.
You're not needed here, Naomi.
Get out.
Jesus, with IQs over 180.
180?
Even the existence of this genome army is a national secret
of the highest order.
We've been hoping to investigate this thing quietly and deal
with it behind closed doors.
I think we're in trouble.
180 IQ.
All right, Foxhound.
And I think we have just a few more after this.
Sorry, I know these take so long, but there's, you know.
High tech special forces unit.
Foxhound!
Your former unit!
And one that I was a commander of.
What's your IQ, Mick?
I have no idea.
I don't think ghosts have an IQ.
They're every bit as good as when I was commanding them.
So they're still around.
There are six members of Foxhound involved in this terrorist
activity.
Psycho Mantis.
Psycho Mantis!
Sniper Wolf.
A beautiful and deadly sharpshooter.
She is beautiful.
Decoy Octopus, Master of Disguise.
Vulcan Raven, Giant and Shaman.
And Revolver Ocelot.
Specialist in interrogation and a formidable gunfighter.
Looks like a lovely bunch of folks.
And finally, in charge of them, the Foxhound Squad Leader.
Liquid Snake.
Liquid Snake!
Yes.
And you're the only person who can stand against him.
Because I'm Solid Snake!
Liquid!
Liquid Snake!
Snake got nothing but questions.
Liquid Snake.
The man with the same codename as you, we should all say
We fought in the Gulf War as a teenager.
Look at that smug mug.
Fresh!
USA.
and destroy mobile scud missile launching platforms when the
usa moved to england upon birth too i believe didn't you
infiltrate he's part of the special force sacks because that
guy sacks myself back then the details are classified but it
seems that originally he penetrated the middle east as a
sleeper for the sis seven languages spy for the british
secret intelligence service but he never once showed his
face in century house he was taken prisoner in iraq and
after that was no trace of him for several years after you
retired he was rescued and became a member of foxhound i
thought that by the time i left they were no longer using
code names i don't know his real name that information is so
highly classified that even i can't look at it here's a
photo of him wonder what his name could be don't say it guys
don't say pretty shocking the white mamba his skin
I have a twin.
I don't know the details, but it seems so.
That's why we really need you for this mission.
You're the only one who can beat him.
Now that I've met you, I know.
You've got something that he doesn't.
I can see it in your eyes.
Why don't I find that thought more comforting?
What do I have?
She speaks in riddles.
A nice butt, yeah.
What do I have, Naomi?
What do I have?
He's got them crazy eyes.
I need to borrow your scissors.
What are you going to do?
Don't worry.
Just going to clean myself up a little.
I don't want to be mistaken for the leader of the
terrorists.
He's so talented.
He can give himself a haircut and everything.
I only cut my bangs.
That's why they're a little crooked.
I only cut my bangs, but they always end up crooked.
I just can't get it right.
I'm going to wait it out so we can see the opening.
Wait, the opening scene is the same.
Is it the same?
I can't remember, actually.
Is the same?
Okay, we'll just do a new game then.
And yes, I will be playing on normal difficulty.
Radar off.
Nihongo.
Why is it saying Nihongo?
I can't read the right.
It's also so hard to read, like, kanji, I think.
Like, I would never recommend someone to learn kanji from an
old video game.
Because it's just all blurry.
Looks like I'm looking at kanji when I need glasses.
It's so crunchy.
Not crunchy.
It's opposite of crunchy.
But yeah, we're going to just be playing on normal.
So, I can't...
Yeah, it's like...
Like something dope.
Nihongo not Joju, okay?
MP5?
No, we're not going to play on so easy, though.
Come on.
David Hayden!
If he didn't cut his hair, he would have easily fooled
everyone that he was liquid snake and reversed everything.
The terrorist died.
I know, right?
Oh.
A
couple of bothersome flies.
But I do know some of the names.
I do recognize some of them sometimes.
Like Doug Stone is the voice of, uh...
Psycho Mantis
This is Snake Colonel, can you hear me?
Loud and clear.
What's the situation, Snake?
Looks like the elevator in the back is the only way up.
Thanks for the super chat to me, guys.
Thank you.
You'll have to take the elevator to the surface.
But make sure nobody sees you.
Okay.
If you need to, contact me by codec.
The frequency is 140.85.
When you want to use the codec, push the select button.
to contact you the codec will beep when you hear that noise
press the select button the codex receiver directly
stimulates the small bones of your ear it tickles but you
will be able to hear it got it okay I'm ready to go hold on
I'll have to remember which one to press okay so it's this
one and then this one is the pause okay good
Okay.
Punch, punch, punch.
I mean, punch, punch, punch.
Grab, grab, grab, grab, grab, grab.
Punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch.
First person!
Ooh.
That's a sound, anyway.
No one will see me.
Not even the rats.
Oh.
Where's the guy?
Where is everybody?
Hello?
Oh, there they are.
I'm like, hello?
Oh, they're converging.
Like, he can't see me from here, right?
I can't remember.
No.
I think we're safe.
And does he turn around here?
I can't remember.
Don't turn around.
Oh.
Ah!
Don't see me!
Okay.
We're good.
We
enjoy all the killing!
I enjoy it!
Delicious killing!
Murder!
I don't want him to hear me.
Which way does he go?
Let's go up, right?
I want the other ration over here.
We're just gonna collect all these rations real quick.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, there we go.
I enjoy all the killing!
Everything's with a 50 gift.
50 gift a thank you.
Maybe I'll kill this guy too.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
So much for my no alerts run.
Which I never was going to do anyway, so it's fine.
Return your projections, everybody.
There's nothing wrong here.
There's nothing wrong here, please.
Time to restart.
No, God, please.
Where does a guy go from?
I can't really.
Oh, there he is.
We'll just go from the other side then.
Oh,
it's so good here.
the original soundtrack.
It's so good.
It's not gonna...
Yeah, that's right.
Go away.
Oh, just...
Oh, what was that?
Oh, nothing?
No one?
Actually, good.
We'll distract him a little bit, and then we'll...
Oh, come on!
Go away!
Go away, mister.
Please, hold on.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
oh come on you bitch you bitches hold on let me how do i
knock again uh which
way does he come okay this way
yippee showing off that 180 IQ huh what was that noise huh
what was that noise huh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh
my gosh oh my gosh here it comes
i love this sequence
it's him that's my guy
the controller like vibrates in that part it's so awesome oh
my gosh oh my gosh so cool
oh shadow moses it's me though
so crunchy
It's snake.
I'm in front of the disposal facility.
Excellent snake.
Age has to slow you down one bit.
Yeah!
How's that sneaking suit working out?
That's great.
I'm nice and dry, but it's a little hard to move.
Bear with it.
It's designed to prevent hypothermia.
This is Alaska, you know.
Take it easy.
I think snakes belong in Alaska.
If it weren't for your suit and your shot, I would have
turned into a popsicle out there.
An anti-freezing peptide snake.
Ooh.
I shouldn't have had coffee.
I'm starting to shake a lot.
I'm relieved to hear that.
I'm already tested, huh?
Um, no.
By the way, how's the diversionary operation going?
Two F-16s just took off from Galena and are headed your way.
The terrorist radar should have already picked them up.
That's so awesome for you.
Though, I will miss the iPatch even though I've never seen
your Facebook.
Behind D.
Colonel.
What's a Russian gunship doing here?
I have no idea.
Oh my god, Snake!
I can't believe we had the same thought!
That's so crazy!
Twinsies!
It's so funny because I was in VR chat.
Like, I think, not yesterday, the day before yesterday.
And there's a recreation of this area, too.
Because I was, like, testing out some stuff.
there's a recreation of this area and I was like we I think
only 18 hours left until their deadline you've got to hurry
done with the codex Wow you must be crazy to fly behind in
this kind of weather oh my god what a cute voice I haven't
introduced you to yet this is Mei Ling she was assigned to
us as our visual and data processing specialist she designed
your codec as well as your soliton radar system contact her
if you have any questions about either of them Nice to meet
you, Snake.
It's an honor to speak to a living legend like yourself.
Oh, silence.
What's wrong?
I just didn't expect a world-class designer of military
technology to be so cute.
Me and you're just flattering me.
No, I'm serious.
Here comes one of my favorite lines.
Well, I know I won't be bored for the next 18 hours.
Come on.
I can't believe I'm being hit on by the famous solid snake.
This one!
But I'm surprised.
for a train killer Frank we both have a lot to learn about
each other oh I'm looking forward to learning about the man
behind the legend oh my god but first oh my god he's so
smooth your solar W Riz the bright dot in the middle is you
snake me the red dots are your enemies and the blue coin
shirt represents their field of vision they can't see me be
careful snake the genome soldiers have highly developed
senses of hearing and vision due thanks the Colonel though
Let them see you.
You should all be fine.
First, I want you to infiltrate the disposal site and look
for the DARPA chief.
Okay.
The DARPA chief was injected with the same GPS transmitting
nanomachines as you.
He should appear on your radar as a green dot.
Green dot.
Get whatever information you can from him about the
terrorists.
If he's alive, that is.
Nah, he's fine.
I believe, I believe, I believe.
Snake, your radar isn't affected by the weather, but if
you're discovered by an enemy, you won't be able to use it.
I think that's a flawed design.
it gets jammed easily i'm afraid yes it's all made from
currently existing technology you won't be able to use it in
an area with strong harmonic resonance so be careful we'll
be monitoring my radar so contact us by codec anytime you
want got it i'll call if i'm feeling technology in phantom
pain is so advanced you're here to back you up so call if
you need some information or advice okay i'm also in charge
of your mission data contact me if you want me to record
your current status my frequency is 140.96 okay it's a
dedicated frequency for saving data don't forget it oh I
won't forget it but oh remember except for your binoculars
you're naked I need to arm yourself with whatever weapons
you can find okay I remember first I'm strip searched by dr.
Naomi here and then all my weapons are taken away imagine
yourself put in that position well if you make it back in
one piece maybe I'll let you do a strip search on me I'll
hold that doctor by the way sorry to disappoint I did manage
to smuggle out my oh my god this is my favorite part in my
stomach thanks to the shot you gave me that suppressed my
stomach acids cigarettes how are those going to help you you
never know this guy just ate his cigarettes he just this guy
is insane if you want to get in yeah there is the front door
It's the fastest way, but there's too much risk of being
spotted by the enemy.
We're just gonna open it up.
I can't just knock on the door and ask them to let me in.
Why not?
There's one sentry on the left.
Why don't we steal their uniforms?
They're armed with five-five-sixers and pineapples.
I love pineapple.
One, two, one, two, three.
What about the air duct near the door?
That's my favorite way to get in.
There should also be a duct on the second floor.
Yes.
But that requires, like, going upstairs and...
I can't see it from here.
Look at him go.
He's got that nerd walk.
I'll let you decide the best COA.
Pushes out cigarettes like a pez candy dispenser.
Okay.
Alrighty.
We're in the game.
So, yeah, like, as you can see, everything the descriptions
are in japanese but like i said we know what things do so i
think we'll be okay for the most part and uh yeah so let's
see um there's a guy that like walks around down here how do
i zoom in oh oh scope wait why isn't it go this is the quick
equip and unequip I remember now why are they JP because
this is integral which was only released in Japan but where
is this guy but for some reason they kept all the dub voices
so it works I don't look this way oh that It looks like a
trap.
Actually, that's a trap.
I know it's possible to get it, but it still scares me.
I think I can kill this guy.
Come
on.
I'm sleepy.
You turn around, you son of a bitch!
Oh my god.
I don't even have a gun yet!
Gosh.
Don't scream like that.
You scare me.
Ah!
Hi!
We're okay.
Wait,
what was the super chat?
Turn around.
Normie, take on how the Sigs were smuggled in and out.
Put them in a Ziploc bag.
Swallows them.
Punch his own stomach or run stomach into some blunt corner
of a hard surface to puke them back up.
How do you know he puked them?
That's all I gotta say.
Return to your positions.
Dummies.
Wait, did it... It didn't summon a new guy, right?
He's still gone.
There's also the security camera, though, that we have to...
Be careful of.
Did I get hit?
My life!
Well, might as well use it.
Wait, how do I use it?
B.
I pressed B.
Maybe here?
Oh, there we go.
No.
Nice.
Nice, ooh.
Maybe looking through here is easier than...
Let's go get there!
Oh.
Let's go get the weapon.
I like how we're just chilling up here.
Oh my god.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Don't be seen.
Hello.
Oh, he's coming?
He doesn't see me.
Sometimes their vision is like so good and sometimes so bad.
I don't understand.
He turns to the left, right?
Yep.
Oh my god.
Yay!
The show come!
So far you're two for two on being seen.
Hey, hey, hey!
Hey, hey, hey.
Also, isn't he supposed to be asleep in front of that
camera?
What are you doing walking around?
on you busy guy you're so busy or something oh my goodness
aren't you supposed to be asleep but
over there am i crazy go to bed different guy i wonder if i
can grab him
he's gonna turn around though right he's gonna turn this way
No, he doesn't.
But then he turns around.
When does he turn around?
I want to get the little cutscene where he goes, a
surveillance camera.
You know?
Oh my god.
That was so close.
Whee!
Not playing on the mint mod.
It's not quite ready yet.
Oh yeah, I meant to say that before.
But it's, um, I was told it's not quite ready yet.
Once it is, we will play on it, no worries.
It's over here, right?
Oh, surveillance camera.
Oh, my God.
I don't want to get caught, though.
Surveillance camera?
Why would they need that?
What, are they trying to be sneaky or something?
Oh, my God.
Go away.
Turn around.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh my god.
Why can't you be asleep?
I'm not going to get caught, am I?
We're fine.
Does this way have anything?
How are you supposed to not get caught there?
Yeah, we'll follow the rats.
I wanted to get this first, though.
Oh, that's right.
We're full.
Okay, never mind.
We're gonna go with a chaff grenade.
But I don't have that.
Like, I know you can't, you can't shoot out the cameras in
this game, right?
For a ghost, you're bad at being invisible.
What?
It's because I'm so comfortable.
I'm so used to being invisible as a ghost.
I'm not so used to being invisible as a human, you know what
I mean?
Snake, this is McDonald Miller.
Master Miller!
What are you doing here?
I quit being a real instructor, so I moved out here for some
peace and quiet.
I'm in retirement just like you.
Once in a while, I still help train the Alaskan Scouts.
Passing on the skills to a new generation, huh?
I love Master Miller!
Campbell told me about the situation here.
This guy makes a mean hamburger.
There's no one I'd rather have in a foxhole than you.
Well, I know lots about survival in a harsh environment.
I've lived in Alaska longer than you.
So call me if you have any questions about the flora or
fauna out here.
I'm gonna call you all the time.
Oh, I should probably like...
Okay, hold on.
Those mice are Alaskan field mice.
Don't worry, they can't hurt you.
Okay.
Wild field mice don't have a thick layer of fat, survive the
bitter winters here without hibernating.
That's crazy.
They dig tunnels under the snow.
That's where they stay warm.
Survival specialists, huh?
I should learn from them.
But there's a dark side too.
Sometimes the males will kill and eat offspring that's not
their own.
To ensure the survival of their own genes, right?
Yeah, pretty brilliant program, huh?
If there are mice, that means there must be an exit
somewhere.
Follow the mice.
Befriend the mice.
Okay, there we go.
Sorry, the Soliton radar won't work in a narrow space.
That's okay.
Too much harmonic resonance.
The radio waves produce interference.
And we can't analyze the topographic data.
You're doing amazing math.
Try to hang on until you get to a more open space, okay?
Okay.
Love you.
Yay.
Don't give up, Snake.
Sorry, the Solitano- Oh, she's just gonna keep saying this.
Well, we'll do the save thing once we're out of the, uh...
Once we're out of the hole.
Those mice are Alaskan field mice.
Don't worry, they can't hurt you.
I just needed reassurance, okay?
I just needed the reassurance.
Oh, we're fine.
We're still...
This feels like Tokyo jungle.
Why does the vent have so much water in it?
This place is...
Um...
I honestly couldn't tell you.
Oh.
He's right here.
Ah!
Stop being so shocked by me.
I'm trying to befriend you.
I have snacks.
Don't you want a ration?
They're like, don't feed us that nastiness.
Look at them go.
We'll wait for him to circle around again.
We gotta go find a diaper chief.
Gross ration.
Does Ration basically like an MRE?
There he is.
Yeah?
Okay.
Thanks for the Super Chat!
Hold on.
One second.
I'm gonna do this real quick.
I'm gonna actually pin a message that says, Please no
spoilers in chat.
Not for me, but for anyone who's new to the series.
We want to have this...
Be safe place for all watchers.
Thank you.
There we go.
And I'll just pin that instead.
Snake dies.
With me playing it, probably.
If I'm the one in control, most likely.
MRE is a specific type of ration.
Oh, he's here, I see.
Here he comes.
Oh, I forgot there's two of them here.
And then he stops.
When he stops there, does he look this way?
I can't remember.
Or bring back the smiley?
Oh, yeah.
Meals ready to eat.
Oh.
I wish I could see him.
There he is.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
That was close, I think.
Oh my god.
The tank area music is just so good.
Oh,
hello?
Use the elevator to change floors.
There should be a cargo elevator that you can take down
somewhere around there.
Try to find it.
Thanks, Colonel!
There's a maid that kills a snake a few times.
Wait, what's the button?
Oh, there we go.
I think I see him.
That little squiggly.
Oh my gosh.
He's really freaking out in there.
He's like...
It's Missing No!
The DARPA chief has turned into Missing No!
Look at the radar.
It's picking up the DARPA chief.
He's the green dot.
Hurry and rescue him.
Oh my god!
Where are we?
Gotta get that guy.
Boop.
Don't.
Nothing here.
I hate how much this game has literally changed my brain.
It has rewired my brain.
If you want to go up or down a ladder, just press the action
button by the ladder.
Like I can't say nothing here normally anymore.
I have to go nothing here.
just because of Metal Gear Solid 2.
It's so insane.
I just can't.
I can't live normally anymore, you guys.
It's a problem.
Wait, do I...
Do I need the rations?
I'm so used to hoarding rations because I always need them,
but I think we're fine for now.
I thought the action button was always triangle.
Am I crazy?
That's why I was like...
Wait.
Because that's how I got into the car, right?
Hmm.
I don't know.
You're crazy.
No, it's, I'm pressing circle.
I thought it was triangle.
Japanese, oh, the Japanese one is different, that's why.
Wait, how do I look down?
Is it action, circle, square, X?
I should just have that equipment, shouldn't I?
Triangle, no.
Circle, no, tilt your head down.
Just use your neck, dummy.
Uh...
Huh.
Triangle plus down.
Or triangle plus down.
Ah, thank you!
Oh, kind of damn cold.
I hate Alaska.
Boy, oh boy, that woman is built.
Well, woman is...
Shit kind of sucks it.
God, I was thinking about women on the toilet.
That's my favorite activity.
Of course I'm gonna think about every woman on the toilet.
Oh,
here we go.
We can see around in there.
Ooh.
Thank you.
Ah, that guy.
What a silly guy on the toilet.
Catching colds in Alaska.
you would think that being in like being you know a super
soldier shouldn't you have a better immune system this guy
just kind of sucks he's he's IQ 179 everyone else is 180 and
he's he's just 179 not him not him the the scary music is so
A woman!
Snake, the DARPA chief's signal is coming from somewhere in
that area.
Isn't there someplace to drop down?
Take a look around in first-person view mode.
I'm looking.
Actually...
Master!
Snake, you've got to think.
Your mind is your most dangerous weapon.
If things are getting too complicated, try to simplify your
thoughts.
You can also try calling Campbell for advice.
Or you, because I'm your master.
Instructor.
Okay, he has a point.
Don't agree with him.
Oh, here we go.
Nice angle.
Oh, who's that?
Who's that?
I'm here to save you.
You're the DARPA chief.
Donald Anderson, right?
You here to save me, huh?
What's your outfit?
I'm the pawn they sent here to save your worthless butt.
It's true.
You don't look like one of them.
George, bud!
Connect, please.
Hurry up and get me out of here.
Slow down.
Don't worry.
First, I want some information about the terrorists.
Yeah.
What do you mean?
Do they really have the ability to launch a nuke?
Why are you so shocked?
The terrorists are threatening the White House.
They say if they don't accede to their demands, they'll
launch a nuclear weapon.
Sweet Jesus.
Is it possible?
How does this guy not know?
It's possible.
Phantom Snake welcome the membership.
Thank you.
What?
How do they plan to launch?
I thought this place was just for keeping the dismantle
warheads.
They shouldn't have access to a missile.
What I'm about to tell you is classified information.
Okay.
I'm ready.
We're conducting exercises with a new type of experimental
weapon.
A weapon that will change the world.
What?
A weapon with the ability to launch a nuclear attack from
any place on the face of the earth.
Gucci sneaking suit 2022.
A nuclear-equipped walking battle tank.
What the...
Uh-oh.
Wait, I thought that was just a rumor.
Ah.
Battle gear.
Battle gear!
be you knew oh my god metal gear is one of the most secret
black projects how did you know that oh my gosh Rex is so
we've had a couple of run-ins in the past so that's the
reason you were here at this disposal site why else did I
come to a god-forsaken place like this I had heard the metal
gear project was scrapped Yeah.
On the contrary.
It's grown into a huge joint project between Amstek and
ourselves.
They made it even better!
We were going to use this exercise as raw data and then
proceed to mass production.
They made him crazy.
They made him roar like a dinosaur.
If it hadn't been for the revolution.
The revolution.
Rex has fallen into the hands of terrorists.
Rex Rex!
Metal Gear Rex!
The code name for the new Metal Gear prototype.
They're probably already finished arming the warhead they
plan to use with Rex.
This guy's like, uh, why are you talking?
They're all experienced in handling and equipping weapons.
Hey!
Shut up in there, will ya?
Wave him away.
Get out of here!
Hey!
in there will ya I'm thinking back to the twin snakes where
he literally like literally spider-man on the ceiling some
kind of detonation code that you have to input oh you mean
pal yes of course there is a pal it's set up so that you
need to input my little buddy my pal my friend there are two
passwords yes Baker knows one and I know one Baker the
president of arms thank you oh Oh, thank you for the 50.
Thank you so much.
Each of us needs to input our password, or there can be no
launch.
But...
But?
They found out my password.
You're so weak.
You talked.
Psycho-Mantis can read people's minds.
You can't resist it.
Psycho-Mantis.
One of the members of Foxhound, he has psychic powers.
Psychic powers.
This is bad.
It's just a matter of time.
before they get bakers to they marry you little creep if
they find out baker's password is dropping yes they'll be
able to launch a nuke anytime oh but there is a way to stop
the launch what the card keys card keys they were designed
by armstack the system developers as an emergency override
oh even without the passwords you can just insert the card
keys and engage the safety lock and if I do that yes yes you
can stop the launch zoom in on the toilet paper that card
key so where are the keys hmm Baker should have them the
card keys you need three card keys there are three different
slots to put them in okay you need to insert a card into
each one of them okay three card keys got it do you know
where they might
somewhere in the second floor basement second floor basement
second floor basement I heard the guards say they moved him
to an area that has a lot of electronic jamming ah any other
clues yes they cemented over the entrances but didn't have
enough time to paint them why don't you look for the areas
where the walls are a different color here take this it's my
ID card it'll open any level one security door.
It's called a pad card.
It works together with your body's own electrical field.
I just noticed are there like bugs on the floor?
It transmits data using the salts in your body as the
transmission medium.
As you approach the door security devices they'll read the
data stored in the card and the doors will open
automatically.
Gotcha.
Yippee.
Okay I'm gonna get you out of here.
Yeah.
what is it you haven't heard any other way to disarm the pal
have you from your bosses or anyone no are you sure you
haven't heard anything no I just said no so does the White
House plan to give in to the terrorist demands that's their
problem it has nothing to do with my orders but what about
the Pentagon Pentagon oh what is it oh the toilet's right
there you can make it What's that?
Diverchief!
Oh!
Hey, what happened?
Oh my God, his stomach was really growling.
I think he has IBS, you guys.
I think he has IBS for real.
Oh!
Huh.
Hmm.
Uh-oh.
Um.
Well, that was bad.
I think he died a bit.
the chief what happened he died of cringe I don't know it
looked like a heart attack but a heart attack no no colonel
are you hiding something from me absolutely not snake you've
got to understand this op is security level red you need the
highest security clearance to get access to the complete
file you want me to believe that you're in charge of this op
but you don't have complete access to the file oh i told you
the secretary of defense is in operational control Where's
your support?
Snake, we don't have time to debate.
Snake hides at the ceiling of the prison.
Um.
Uh.
Oh.
What's going on out there?
Yeah.
Oh.
Huh?
Yeah?
You think it's safe?
What could it be?
They're just little pixels on the ground.
Eww!
I died here!
Besides this guy.
Um... Oh!
killed the chief you bastard it wasn't me
liquid no you're not liquid just don't move the way he looks
like he's in springing action is this the first time you
ever pointed a gun at a person your hands are shaking you
got them rookie eyes careful i'm no rookie liar that nervous
glance That scared look in your eyes.
Rookie, rookie, rookie.
They're rookie's eyes if I ever saw them.
Screams rookie.
You've never shot a person, am I right?
You talk too much.
You haven't even taken the safety off, rookie.
I told you I'm no rookie.
Uh-oh.
They've heard him.
Not one of them, are you?
Ha!
I never knew how they...
You've got a card, don't you?
Why?
How they, like...
So we can get the hell out of here!
Come in, you know?
Looks like we'll be a little delayed.
I never understood why they show up here.
What are you doing?
Don't think!
Shoot!
Don't think shoot.
That's so...
Wait, how do I shoot?
X button.
Waiting
for him.
Shoot!
Don't talk to me like a rookie.
I was telling you, shoot!
Yeah!
But him saying like, don't think shoot is so top gun.
So funny.
Nice.
Good job, guys.
Oh, I'm out of bullets.
I just saw it as soon as I ran back over.
Shoot!
Oh, wait.
Why did I use that when I...
Should I just...
Shoot!
Always gets me, too.
Thanks for the help.
Hey.
Oh.
Wait.
Wow!
That's a nice butt!
Nice tush!
You fool!
You've killed him!
I'm sorry, sir.
His mental shielding was very strong.
I could not dive into his mind.
Now we'll never get that detonation code.
Huh?
Still happy that you're back.
Thank you.
Wait, huh?
Who did they kill?
Wow, she's just emptying her entire thing.
Yeah!
Psycho Mantis...
Good girl, just like that!
He called Snake a good girl.
Naomi, I just had some kind of hallucination.
I'm going crazy.
Is it from the nanomachines?
No, Snake.
The nanomachines are functioning properly.
So what was it?
It must have been psychometric interference coming from
Psycho Mantis.
Foxhound Psychic.
Think of it as a mental feedback loop.
So that was Mantis.
That guy's crazy.
Wait, what is the...
What is the... How do I get in here?
This little pants.
He's a boxers type of guy.
Wait, is this boxers or is this briefs?
Here, I'll give you a better angle.
Boxers are... Those are boxers.
Briefs?
Which one?
Which bed has the...
So let's unequip that.
This way.
Excuse me, sir.
I'm just gonna steal the stuff under your butt.
Fight sequence.
It was one of the instances where you have to kill to
progress the game even on big boss rank, which limits your
kills.
Yeah!
That's so interesting.
I did think about that, like...
Anything in here?
We're so common.
Isn't in Twin Snakes you get the magazine in here, though,
right?
So nasty.
You're a nasty fella.
Mysterious man.
We don't know your name yet.
If you even have a name.
Oh, I already...
Wait.
I don't have full life, so...
I guess we'll come back for this ration if we ever need it.
And we can't.
Boop, boop.
Boop.
Boop boop Alright, second floor basement Yeah, see I'm
pressing circle It's so weird But I thought I pressed
Triangle to get into the truck Hmm I'm not I'm not sure
Second floor basement Second floor basement
Hmm Hmm Hmm There's no one here yet, right?
Pretty sure.
Pretty sure we're safe.
Besides the floors.
The floors open up here, and they're quite evil.
Ah!
You go go go!
Sandplex, thank you so much for the pink!
Still remember playing this at my cousin's place.
Never had the chance to finish it.
Well, let's finish it together!
Bye-bye!
It's this one here, right?
Grenades.
I don't remember if any of them.
It doesn't need a name.
Sure, we'll never see him again.
This one also...
I'm so paranoid.
I'm so paranoid if any of them has lasers.
This is level two.
Oh, the FAMAS.
Okay, let's try and remember these.
FAMAS is in here.
Nikita missiles in here
C4 in here And this is Stinger?
Oh, yeah, not, yes.
PSG No, this is Sorry.
Sniper Here.
Okay.
And then what's And then the And then we got the grenades
down here.
this this is a sniper actually i in my brain i knew it was a
sniper i promise you i'm not lying i'm not where's the trap
doors we literally walked over with chatters are discussing
solid snakes nakedness or what looks like nakedness in the
metal gear solid game the boxer briefs theory seems to be
the most popular concept wait there's something what is what
is a boxer briefs
Whoa!
Wait a second.
Do I have to use the grenade?
Oh gosh.
I thought I used C4 here.
Where- which- where's the C4 room?
It was this one.
Aha!
Let's just unequip these so I don't accidentally miss them.
Oh, these look like lockers for a second.
What's it say?
No smoking!
There we go.
X button, B button.
I wish it...
Okay, I think...
Okay.
There we go.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run, run, run.
Nice.
Okay.
They said it's in a place with jamming.
Oh!
Nothing here.
Except a weirdly colored wall!
Before we move on...
I need to use the little ghosties room.
Oh, so, um...
We haven't called master in a minute.
Let's see what he has to say.
Soldiers that have been forged in the final...
of battle are used to catching naps whenever and wherever
there's a big difference between real soldiers and those
kids who have only been trained in VR simulators that's not
I'm a real soldier for a long time you should get some rest
too oh it hasn't even been that long master hasn't even been
two hours I was gonna say you please backseat me on the
codex I ask you to because because I've played before I'll
forget to call them so please if you're just like hey you
haven't called Campbell in a while or you haven't called
master Miller you haven't called someone oh yeah Nistasha
let's get her what is it one four one five two wait wait how
do I one four one five two oh oopsie bye bye there we go
This is Nostasha Romanenko.
A pleasure to work with you, Solid Snake.
Thank you.
You're the nuclear specialist that the Colonel mentioned.
That's me.
You can ask me anything about nooks that you want.
I am also a military analyst, so I have an extensive
knowledge of weapon systems as well.
Ooh, la-la.
They ask me to participate in this operation as a supervisor
from the Nuclear Emergency Search Team.
I was happy to accept.
to get their hands on nuclear weapons of any kind no I hope
I can help you to stop them you're a tough lady those
terrorists are serious about launching a nuclear weapon the
world cannot stand by idly and allow that to happen and
neither I love idly unfortunately all I can do from here is
provide a cigarette I think so hopefully that'll be enough
another soldier here wouldn't make a difference anyway it's
good to work with you nostalgia same here snake same here
snake so yeah if i if i forget after some time if you're
just like hey save or whatever i don't mind that kind of
backhand you can't use your radar in that area there's some
kind of electronic jamming coming from there i wonder what
it is anyway be careful actually what is it that's jamming
this area have
my babies please First of all, her name's Nastasha, not
Natasha.
I don't think she's going to have your babies if you can't
get her name right.
You can at least do...
You can at least have that common courtesy for her, you
know?
Elris.
Be careful, Snake.
No, I want... I want...
Where's my proverb?
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to call again.
Snake, you can't use your...
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Thank you.
hold on let's go into the other area and get our silly
little mailing face
what's up snake what's up snake talk to you later snake bye
what can i do for you snake nothing be careful snake thank
you she's so cute she's so sweet she's so cute you called
snake come on snake don't call me for no reason Any other
reason to see her cute little face?
Uh-oh.
She's pouting her cheeks up.
She's pouting her cheeks at me.
Ah, so close.
Next one, maybe.
Do not save.
Be...
It's so good every time.
It's so good!
Okay, give me one second.
I'm gonna go fishing.
Gone fishes.
BRB, I'm going to the ghost's room.
Sorry, I had too much coffee.
And tea.
I'll be right back.
I'll be fast.
I don't know where my phone is.
Hmm.
I don't think I brought it.
Oops.
I don't know where I put my phone.
Uh-oh.
I like to check if I have any missed messages or anything
while I'm...
while I'm peeing.
I'm buck.
Oh, I should have gotten more tea.
That's okay.
bit i have a cut on my lip and it hurts every time i smile
so i'm just gonna i'm gonna frown the whole stream ouch is
because when i had um when i had i get really dry lips and
when i had covid i didn't want to use any of my lip bombs
because i was like I'll have to get rid of them afterwards
because they'll be infected.
Snake, remember what Confucius said.
The man who runs in front of a car gets tired, but the man
who runs behind a car gets exhausted.
MTS Sneaking Music A is a bar channel.
Uh-oh.
Ah.
Wait.
Oh, okay, good, good, good.
Sorry.
I thought, uh...
I thought my controller turned off.
Why didn't you just use your finger?
Because it's not like the fingery type.
It's not like the ones that you...
It's not like the one you squeeze.
So...
Manifficity.
I can't cut on them.
Yeah.
Anyway, let's actually save.
Oh, she's still mad at me.
I'm gonna save this time!
Me-Ling, please believe me!
I'm gonna save, I'm gonna save!
Wait, didn't I just save?
You know what, it's fine.
Taco melon, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Thank you guys for all the doughnuts while I was gone too.
Snake, listen to what Lo Chi said.
He who knows that enough is enough will always have enough.
Just because you see an item doesn't mean that you always
have to get it.
If you don't really need it, think twice before you stick
your neck out.
It might not be worth it.
Don't tell me that.
That's my least favorite.
One melee.
Good.
Looks like it worked.
If what the DARPA chief said is true, President Baker should
be up ahead.
Hurry up and get him out of there.
Okay.
We'll get him.
Easy peasy.
Don't tell me what to do.
Oh, I'm still gone fishing.
My bad.
Thank you.
Let's...
Let's go.
Oh.
Let's...
Oh, whoops.
Huh.
I don't even think if they had painted over it, it would
have...
It would have made a difference.
First of all, why are they so, like, haphazardly...
Like, why aren't they just doors?
Like, are...
Did this hallway just lead to nowhere?
Like, what's... what's the deal, yo?
What was the...
Why aren't they, like, square shaped, like, a normal door.
I'm just so...
I'm so confused.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
I should go... I'm gonna go grab some more C4 actually.
So that we have it.
So that we have it before we continue onwards, you know?
So I don't have to come back in here is what I want.
Which I might just have to anyway but you know it's fine
gonna see four cheese here no i think i'll do it normally
this wasn't a particularly difficult fight so i think it's
okay
and i think some
people had real trouble with this boss their first time i
guess we'll see maybe i got lucky i don't know Just
remembering the Twin Snakes version of this fight and how
ridiculously easy it was.
I want to go back to the Twin Snakes for all the boss
fights.
Here we go!
What could be in here?
Who's that?
Oh my god.
Am I too late?
You got...
Ooh, there's a little sexy going on here.
He's alive.
President Kenneth Baker, right?
Don't worry, I'm here to save you!
No, no, don't touch it!
C4.
Don't touch it!
I'm close!
Right.
Touch that wire, and the C4 will blow up along with the old
man.
So you're the one that the boss keeps talking about.
And you?
Special operations, Foxhound.
I've been waiting for you, Solid Snake.
Now we'll see if the man can live up to the legend.
This is the greatest handgun ever made.
The cult's single action arm.
It's more than enough to kill anything that means.
Oh my god, he said the thing.
I'm sorry.
Now I'll show you why they call me.
Revolve.
He's so awesome.
DRAW!
I forgot to...
Oh, uh...
Ow!
Oh my god.
The lady won't help you.
I understand the bullet tree.
Wait.
I'm confused.
Wait, why is my thing not equipping?
That was weird.
Okay, um, ouch!
Oh my gosh.
I'm guessing, I'm guessing.
Live.
Let's go.
I'm just guessing, I'm just guessing.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay.
Oh my god, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I forget the strat a little bit with this one, but...
Ugh.
Oh my god.
Oh, oh my god.
I can't I can't do the same thing he does.
Oh shoot.
He's over there.
I missed my shot.
Oh, no, I didn't Oh my god.
Ouch.
Where's the rations?
There are some here, right?
Where are you?
Oh, where are you?
Come here.
Come here, you little bitch.
But you should be the smell of your own.
Where is he?
Ow!
Oh my god.
Please!
I just...
I almost had him.
Come on!
Where are you at?
Where
is he at actually?
Oh, there he is.
Get him!
Ugh!
Infinity frames.
Where are you at?
Ah!
We're dancing over here.
Oh my gosh, you guys were dead!
What are you gonna do, Asala?
What are you...
Are you gonna shoot me?
What are you gonna do?
Come on!
Shoot me, Asala!
Oh, that was close.
That was close.
That was really close.
I know he runs here.
Oh,
shoot.
Where are you?
Oh.
You're pretty good Just what I'd expect from the man with
the same code as the boss It's been a long time since I had
such a good fight But I'm just getting warmed up Look at him
go, you're so...
What?
My hand!
He sounds so not Acelot when he says that Oh my god!
Kenneth!
Stealth camouflage can't you even die right you were lucky
we'll meet again we'll meet again who are you i like you i
have no name i have a name i have a name just like that that
exoskeleton
He killed Kenny!
Not yet, not yet.
So funny.
Oh my god.
Who the hell?
I'm just one Oslo.
I had the best trip I am.
Can you talk?
Who are you?
I'm not one of them.
The DARPA chief told me he gave them his detonation code.
What about yours?
Oh, I get it.
Jim sends you.
Yeah.
Answer my question.
Jim, Jim, Jim, Jim.
What about your code?
time I talked what now the terrorists have both codes and
can launch any time that was the guy like I didn't fight Jim
I managed to resist Psycho Mantis's mind probe he couldn't
read you how'd you do it surgical implants in my brain
surgical implants kind of like a psychic insulation everyone
who knows these top secret codes has it even the DARPA chief
of course but the DARPA chief said Mantis got his code by
reading his mind.
Yeah, how then...
Are you sure you heard him right?
Yeah, that's what he said.
I'm sure.
In that case, how did they get your code?
I never had any training on how to resist torture.
They gave you the psychic resistance, but torture is not as
important, I guess?
Oh, he's not human.
I tell you, he loved every second of it.
What happened to your arm?
I see that.
He loves it.
This guy's a wimp.
His was sliced off.
You're a funny man.
So the DARPA chief, is he okay?
I can't be.
No, that's not what you promised him.
That's not what you promised him.
Now you want to shut me up.
Calm down.
What's wrong with you?
I just told you I was here to save you.
Now kiss.
I didn't kill the DARPA chief.
He had a heart attack or something.
You think?
A heart attack?
No.
Oh, don't be a fool.
Anyway, the terrorists have both codes now.
It's a very convenient time to have a heart attack.
Those boys are totally insane.
They wouldn't hesitate to launch.
I agree.
But what do they really want?
Who knows?
Maybe they're like us in the arms industry.
Always looking forward to the next good war.
Well, I'm not gonna let these maniacs start a war today.
You still have the card keys.
Card keys?
To override the detonation code.
I heard you had them.
Oh.
No, not anymore.
What?
Who does then?
Not the terrorists.
No.
That woman.
woman who the one with the nice but soldier that was thrown
in prison along with me a female soldier it must be she said
she had just joined up as a new recruit oh my gosh they
threw her in prison because she refused to take part in the
rebellion there's no other women here could that be the
colonel's niece what if he meant sniper I gave her the key
looks like she managed to break out of here though I hope
she's okay I'm sure she is she's green but as tough as they
come but how did you know she escaped i was in contact with
her by codec oh until i was tied up here that is codec codec
yes she stole it from the guard if she still has it you
should be able to contact her okay what's her what's your
frequency what frequency was she at yeah let me tell you
it's it's oh gosh abbs no sorry i forgot damn
that's right it should be on the back of the cd case try to
contact her i'll contact her right away okay but tell me if
this doesn't work is there some other way to prevent the
missile launch
hmm you need to find hal emmerick one of my employees who's
that the team leader of the metal gear rex project he sounds
like a he sounds like a nerd but a little bit of an oddball
if there's anyone who can figure out how to stop metal gear
from launching it's him what if he can't come up with
anything.
You'll have to destroy it.
Emmerich knows how to destroy Metal Gear.
Where is this, Emmerich?
Well, he's probably being held somewhere in the Nuclear
Warhead storage building.
Okay.
It's north from here.
That's where he worked.
I know where that is.
I understand, but why Metal Gear?
The Nuclear Age ended with the turn of the Millennium.
Oh, you're wrong.
The threat of Nuclear War isn't gone.
In fact, it's greater than it's ever been.
Real footage!
Plutonium is increasing even today.
Listen, have you ever seen a warehouse full of nuclear
material?
Drums and drums of nuclear waste stack this high.
As far as you can see, because there's still no real way to
dispose of the stuff.
So they just close the lid and try to pretend like it'll go
away?
Essentially, yes.
Oh my god.
And you're not even doing a good job of storing it.
Many of the drums are corroded.
Oh god!
With nuclear waste seeping out of them.
Let's get into my food!
So you mean to have nuclear waste and microplastics to worry
about?
It proves that there's a large and well-organized black
market in nuclear materials.
Furthermore, since the end of the Cold War, Russian nuclear
engineers in particular are out of work with no way to turn.
Cyborg Ninja has an alternate skin that resembles
Spider-Man.
What?
I've never heard that before.
We live in an age when any small country can have a nuclear
weapons program.
What about the other superpowers?
Russia and China still maintain a significant nuclear
presence.
Complete nuclear disarmament is an impossibility.
To maintain our own policy of deterrence, we need a weapon
of overwhelming power.
You mean metal gear?
Yes.
You know our industry suffered quite a blow as a result of
the cuts in military budgets due to this so-called peace.
I remember hearing a lot about mergers and takeovers among
the big weapons makers.
Yes, and after my company lost their bid to produce the Air
Force's next line of fighter jet, the Metal Gear system was
our last ace in the hole.
That's why we pushed to have Metal Gear developed as a black
project.
Black project.
Secret projects paid for by the Pentagon's black budget.
You can avoid a lot of red tape and get a great lead time on
your weapons production.
And no one can bother you.
Not even those bleeding hard liberals on the military
oversight committee Love the turns Lost in the story, they
give it the time to Brimes I prefer to think of it as good
business Anyway, Metal Gear was going to be formally adopted
After the results of this exercise Oh my gosh, that's not
that super detective Timing is so perfectly That's about
what I've expected of a grunt like you Here, this is what
you came for, right?
that an optical disc it's all here the main hard drive was
destroyed by gunfire this is the only remaining copy of the
data what kind of data are all the data collected from this
exercise don't pay it's the way I know you were sent to get
to I hid it from that statistic maniac while he was
torturing me they don't know this disc exists make sure you
report this to Jim to your boss I don't report to Jim I'll
give you my card too Oh, thanks.
It'll open up all security level two doors.
Can you walk?
No.
No, you go on, Madafmi.
They got my password.
They don't want anything else from me.
I have one more question.
Who or what was that ninja thing?
Yeah, who was that?
It looked like you knew something.
That ninja?
Who was that ninja?
That's Hound's dark little secret.
Dark little secret.
An experimental genome soldier.
Ew.
Cover your mouth.
You know him?
You should ask Dr. Naomi Hunter from Foxhound.
She knows better than I.
Oh, Naomi Sass.
Naomi Sass, Naomi Sass, Naomi Sass, Naomi Sass.
If it goes public, my company and I are finished.
I'm going to be playing more Metal Gear.
Metal Gear?
Yes.
Doesn't Metal Gear use currently existing technology?
Thanks for being.
Metal Gear itself does.
Oh, I heard his tummy.
He was gurgling.
What did you do to me?
Oh, no.
Oh, no, it can't be those Pentagon bastards so they actually
went in did it.
What are you talking about?
They're just using you for...
Oh!
That's tummy hurt!
IBS, IBS, IBS, IBS, IBS.
Kenny!
Those bastards!
They killed Kenny!
Colonel, are you listening?
Now he's dead too.
I have no idea.
Don't lie to me.
It looked like another heart attack, but...
Yeah, I...
What do you know, Miss Naomi?
Well, there are lots of drugs that can cause a heart attack
in large doses.
For example, potassium chloride or dioxides, but we won't be
able to tell without doing an autopsy.
Damn!
Snake, I want you and Merrill to work together.
can I trust her more than you can trust me oh get in contact
with her snake there's a lot of electrical interference
coming from there it should be okay if you do burst
transmission like us but normal transmission is probably
impossible try moving away from that area love that line so
much snake get a hold of yourself Naomi what the hell was
that ninja thing yeah you have some explaining to do no are
you sure yes we have no one like that in she had a look on
her face I'm counting on you she she looked concerned for a
moment oh thank goodness oh I got an achievement versus
revolver Ocelot the beat revolver Ocelot nice oh he's dead
IBS was there blood on him is that like see that red there
hmm is there any other ration in here or no
other ration.
Oh, beep beep.
Four.
I don't think I've ever gone through this door before.
I don't remember ever going through this door.
It's so funny.
And then here there's that.
Can't see me now though, right?
I can probably get that ration.
Raaat!
Nice.
I think there's other security cameras down the way, right?
I can't go in through here, though, right?
Or, like, rather, there's no reason for me to go down there
right now because I don't think I can go through any of the
doors.
I'm not even noticed that.
Nice one.
Oh, not once?
I thought you said nice one.
I just complimented myself.
I just completely complimented myself by misreading your own
comment.
Thanks.
Nice one, Mint.
Thanks, Mint.
Thanks!
Oh!
We go into the void.
But now that we go back in here...
I forgot to mention this yesterday, but I got the postcard.
I don't... Wait, hold on.
Oh shoot.
Can I go in here?
Oh, uh, I wouldn't know.
I can!
Okay.
I don't remember what places have the...
We're just gonna be safe on all accounts.
Grenade.
Oh, wait.
This is the grenade room.
It's safe.
I forgot to mention this yesterday, but I got the postcard.
I don't care that it has a tire mark on it.
It gives character.
Well, we care.
But I'm...
Thank you.
Thanks for signing up.
I'm glad you got it.
But yeah, we really do care that it has the tire mark on it.
in the podcast we recorded yesterday actually and i called
it i called it a skid mark and and matara was just like what
what did you say why did you call it that do you know what
that means i was like what are you talking about like a like
a skid mark on the road like a tire skid mark she was like
that's not what that means and i had to like look it up mid
recording i was like yes And literally the first definition
of it was a tie, like a tie or skid mark.
I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't exist like this anymore,
you guys.
I can't keep, I can't keep not living like this.
I swear to God.
I swear.
This is happening every day of my afterlife.
I can't do this anymore.
I can't.
I can't keep living in paranoia.
of everything what else are you supposed to say tie your
marks I guess I don't know I don't know I can't I didn't
know I didn't know can't believe you raw dog that's in my
life raw dogging life without everything What is a skin mark
then?
It's apparently like, I don't want to say it.
It's gross.
If you Google skin marks, the first definition was like a
tire mark on the road.
And then the second was the definition that she was thinking
of.
I just, I never think of that.
Do do residue.
Do do residue do.
Residue do.
That's what it is.
Just don't turn on Google image search.
Okay, so funny that you mentioned that, because...
For some reason, when I look stuff up, I, like,
instinctually go to Google images.
I don't know why.
But I was, like, laughing because...
There was, like, a board game or something, like a
children's game that was called Skin Marks or something.
thing and you play as a dog that were like you put like a
brown pencil in it and it's like a drawing game and i just
can't i can't i can't and like the dog like scoots around on
its butt but doesn't that mean like it has worms and stuff
it's just so oh god hold on i take a sipy
The things they make for children are truly abhorrent
sometimes, I swear.
Okay, I'm gonna go choke this guy.
Oh, we're fine.
We're fine.
He's dead.
Just run away.
There we go.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Don't worry about it.
I always run into them when I'm trying to choke them out, I
swear.
Spend your afterlife frog dogging herpes.
Stop it.
I'm not gonna...
Do I need like an urban dictionary stream?
I swear.
Okay.
I always run into them when I'm choking them.
But it's okay.
We got him.
She tried Gakumas?
Gakumas?
No.
I haven't tried it yet.
This one was safe, right?
Oh, good, good, good.
Wait.
Is this...
Oh, no.
And then this guy comes.
comes down this way, right?
Yeah.
His looks up.
Oh.
So we're gonna go to...
Oh wait, was anything level 2?
I don't think so.
Speaking of the board game, the Metal Gear Solid board game
ships...
Oh yes!
Yes, I know, I know, I'm so excited for it.
Just waiting for him to leave.
Waiting for this guy to leave.
Go away, so I can take the elevator, please.
I took a one-step!
I took one step!
That's insanity.
Oh my god.
I cannot believe that actually happened.
Can I get the... Wait, what else can I get here?
I can't remember.
Ha.
Ha ha.
Ha indeed.
Ha.
Normal people are like the dictionary.
La la la.
Back it up, back it up, back it up, baby.
Yeah, these ones don't move.
Okay.
Alright, Snake.
There you go, there you go.
Nice and easy.
Okay, now he comes down.
Okay.
Woo!
We can probably take this guy out then.
Oh!
Shoot!
Oh, thank you.
We're fine.
Nothing.
Hey.
Don't come in here.
I swear.
Yeah, return to your position!
Oh, man.
I reset.
I should have just shot him, shouldn't I?
Well.
Okay, now I have to wait.
Actually, which way does this?
Does he go down or does he go up?
He goes up, right?
Stealth, you guys, I swear.
Why do I even engage?
You know?
We're fine.
When do I get a box, man?
I feel so naked.
Okay,
um...
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Is it in here?
Ah, okay, all right.
I was like, wait a second.
I think it actually is around here.
Yippee!
I need more rational.
Yikes.
When will it let me hoard more?
I swear.
Oh!
Oh gosh, it's always this guy that really messes me up.
He's always like, huh?
What was that noise?
There's no one else over here, right?
Huh?
What was that noise?
I see you, I see you.
In fact, we'll just box it for now.
Sneaky, sneaky, sneaky.
Call people in the box, right?
Cable, look!
Don't make too much noise or you'll be spotted.
Be careful when you're walking on that floor.
Oh, yeah, I know.
Oh, I, I know.
Look, look, look!
Don't make too much noise.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Cable, Campbell!
Be careful when you're walking on that floor.
Colonel, Colonel, Colonel, Colonel!
Colonel, Colonel!
Colonel!
i'm like
what have you got there a cardboard box yeah remember that
trick that's the snake i remember those poor fools won't
know what hit them i know actually probably nastasia has a
ton of info let's let's let her info dump for a second a
cardboard box a cardboard box usually consists of a thin
pasteboard with a corrugated paper center they are usually
made of recycled paper it was first 100 years ago.
It was originally used to absorb sweat when wearing hats.
Wait, really?
The same amount of wood to make one wooden box.
You can make six or seven cardboard boxes.
And since it's recyclable, it's highly economical.
In addition, it's strong and easy to throw.
That's why it's widely used for packing.
But to avoid damaging weapons and other delicate instruments
when shipping them, they should be packed in stronger boxes
like wrong guys boxes also the crevices should be filled
with styrofoam she sounds she's her accents are great so
anyway once we see box i just like it oh nothing no big deal
she like she mansplains the a cardboard box to me and then
she's like so why are you in it and he's like he's like he
gets like embarrassed about it master a cardboard box huh
just like Zanzibar just like Zanzibar a few times in outer
heaven too getting the maximum use out of ordinary on-hand
objects is the first principle of survival it's especially
important in covert operations I haven't forgotten what you
taught me master you've taught me so much you've taught me
so much master first the DARPA chief and then president
Baker die yeah it's really sucks man.
Yeah, it smells pretty rotten.
Yeah, very rotten.
Master, do you know anything?
No.
But there's definitely something going on.
Keep your eyes open out there.
Okay.
My eyes are peeled.
Gamble.
The DARPA chief and President Baker.
So now the terrorists know both detonation codes.
So they can launch at any time.
On top of that, they both died right in front of my eyes.
codes.
The only way to stop a nuclear launch is to either use the
detonation code release keys that Merrill's holding or or
find the Metal Gear chief engineer that President Baker
mentioned.
Hal Emmerich!
In any case, you should contact Merrill by Kodak.
Wasn't there a frequency written on the back of the CD case?
Yes, we're out of there now.
I completely forgot.
Let's contact Merrill.
Okay.
The back of the CD case.
Why?
140.15.
Who are you?
I was really impressed with the way you busted yourself out
of there.
The one from the prison?
You're the Colonel's niece, Meryl, right?
No, it's not him.
Just exactly who are you?
I'm the fool that your uncle sent all alone into the middle
of this whole mess.
You came by yourself?
You think you're some kind of one-man army?
Oh, I know I'm some kind of one-man army.
You're just like your uncle, you know.
How do you know my uncle?
We go way back.
What's your name?
My name's not important.
Aha.
Could you be Snake?
Are you Solid Snake?
Oh my god!
That's what some people call me.
The legendary Solid Snake?
You?
Oh, style.
Sorry about before.
I wasn't sure if you were one of the good guys.
But I knew you were.
How?
It's your eyes.
My eyes.
They're not soldiers.
eyes and they're rookies eyes right no they're beautiful
compassionate oh just what I'd expect from the legendary
solid snake stop that she's had psychotherapy don't worry
you'll land back on them once you meet me the reality is no
match for the legend I'm afraid oh I don't believe that why
did you look so surprised when you saw my face because you
look just like him you mean the terrorist leader liquid
snake yeah you know him you're not brothers are you i have
no family so what's the deal then who knows why don't you
why would he look just like me then but first i want some
information you were involved in this exercise from the
beginning what exactly happened here i'm sorry i was
captured along with president baker right after the
terrorist attack yeah that's okay but what is this place i
don't think it's just a nuclear weapons disposal facility
boy oh boy it's just like them nobody told you anything did
they nope okay you see this place isn't really for disposing
nuclear weapons what this base is owned and operated by a
dummy corporation of arms this is a civilian base right for
the development of metal gear metal gear Colonel Foxhound
and the next generation special forces were called here for
the test launching of a dummy nuclear warhead oh my god why
Foxhound because they're a special ops group used to
handling top-secret they could help keep it all hush hush
but we must have fired nuclear warheads before why just this
time I don't drop there's gonna be a lot of I don't test
before the formal adoption of the metal gear program but
that's yeah a whole lot of those sounds kind of fishy this
whole thing is fishy sorry I'm not sure I was captured with
president we know what they want revolt started they want
big bosses DNA gave you the detonation code override keys
right that's right amazing you were able to keep him hidden
from the guards well women they're gonna get his body back
they're gonna get his body back you met Baker huh how's he
holding up he's dead what heart attack done the chief the
chief died from a heart attack too yeah it's really it's
really suspicious no not that I heard of well I don't
believe in coincidences something funny is going on sounds
like it but i have no idea what me neither yet do you know
the person who designed metal gear how you mean dr emmerich
yeah i'm sorry i'm on a first name basis with him he should
be in the research lab i'm like oh you know how we go way
back storage building to that one second floor i've watched
second floor basement that's where his lab is i think
they're forcing him to work on the nuclear launch again shot
every time they mention metal gear oh gosh
attack you're right in case we can't override the detonation
code in time I need to ask him how to destroy metal gear you
plan to take that thing on by yourself snake it won't be the
first time what's the best way to get to the building where
the doctor is being held there's a cargo door no I just
realized we're gonna have to fight the tank I forgot about
that what's the security level five I've got a level five
card can you give it to me I've got to go save the you
should go I'm going with you no way no way I'm not green oh
yes you are you pause for just one second in front of your
enemy and it's all over good luck doesn't last forever I
don't know what happened I just couldn't pull the trigger
right away I never had any problems in training when I
thought about my bullets tearing through those soldiers
bodies I hesitated shooting at people are different ever
since I was a little girl I always dreamed about being a
soldier every day of my life I've trained my mind and body
for the one day I could finally see some real action and now
so what now you want to quit I can't quit I can't allow
myself to quit now listen Merrill everybody feels sick the
first time they kill someone yikes unfortunately killing is
one of those easier the more you do it in a war all of
mankind's worst emotions worst traits come out it's easy to
forget what a sin is in the middle of a battlefield but this
isn't a war it's a terrorist action you're just a little
jumpy from the combat it's still yeah it's still combat
stream is starting to thin out just take it easy but I
learned all about combat high at the Academy we'll talk
about it later for now just think about keeping yourself
alive If I get out of here alive, I'll think about that
other stuff.
Because I don't have it in the Twin Snakes.
Let me try to say this another way.
It's like so...
Stay the hell out of my way.
Ugh.
You're a real bastard.
Just like my uncle said.
I told you, the real me is no match for the legend.
It looks like you were right.
Okay, Snake, I'll be a good girl.
We'll link up after I grab the doctor, and then we'll take
care of the dead Code override.
But listen, I know this area better than you.
Call me if you have any questions.
Be careful, okay?
You said you'll be a good cargo door.
I'll contact you.
Open the car, uh, open the door for me.
The cargo door for me.
Open the door for me.
That guy's right there.
I know I gotta go get some thermal cargo.
They're in that one right there, right?
Up there?
Or is it the night vision?
If I walk, the guy below will hear me, so hold on.
Actually, I'll just crawl.
We'll just...
You can't get them now?
You can only get them after the tank.
Wait, oh, so I have to use the cigarettes?
Okay, we'll just chill then.
We'll just wait for her to open the door.
what's the one um in that room oh downstairs i can go in
there though right there's oh already snake i unlocked the
cargo door for you thanks where are you where i can see you
don't move around too much don't worry i'm disguised in this
enemy uniform you won't be for long with the way you
Don't worry about it.
It's equipped with infrared sensors.
Too late for the goggles?
How is it too late?
Gas.
Okay, so we'll meet at the nuclear warhead storage building.
Hey, you said you'd be a good girl.
You said you'd stay put and be a good girl.
I changed my mind.
That was fast.
Don't get careless.
That's when things always turn sour.
Sorry, but this is the only way I can figure out whether or
not I'm cut out to be a soldier.
not too late these guys are professionals you're gonna get
yourself killed see you there oh it's a it's a glitch to get
it um and that's not that's not that's not fair it's not
real oh my god one time i was playing this game and i was i
was down there in that room in the one below in the down the
that one and i um i got killed or no no not I didn't get
killed.
I triggered an alert as the cargo door was opening.
And so it, like, mid-cut scene closed the cargo door.
As I was trying to...
As I was trying to, like...
I was in cutscene, but the guy was, like, shooting at me.
It was so funny.
Oh, gosh.
I need more ration.
I think I will try and get the suppressor, though.
It would probably be good to have.
Oh, I think.
It might be good to have.
Wait, does that guy walk over this way?
Yes.
We're just gonna hold out.
We're gonna hold out.
That guy's right there.
He might hear my footsteps.
We're gonna wait for him to go away.
A little bit.
Oh my god.
He's right there.
Ah,
he was right there.
I thought he left.
Oh my gosh.
Is he gone?
Clearly he's blind.
And...
Oh.
Why did you turn?
I forgot that it...
That it, that it, like...
Wait.
My bomb.
I forgot that it, like, shows up, you know?
Wait, do I have to call her again?
again shoot yes I do hold on I have to look at the back of
the box 140.15 it's already there oh wait oh no it's not I
can't even read so now the terrorists know both detonation
codes yeah yeah yeah I think we I think we did this one okay
mooned mooned oh uh uh no no oh that's fine In any case, you
should contact Meryl by Kodak.
Wasn't her frequency written on the back of the CD case?
No.
Okay, here we go.
15.
I have to look at it every time, you guys.
Also, I'm not good at remembering Kodak numbers.
I was really impressed.
I'm going to skip all this because we went through it, so
don't worry about it.
Do we got to go upstairs for an item again?
Yeah, but it's okay because we have to wait for her to open
the door anyway, so...
second second floor basement be a good girl
okay be a good girl okay
where is that guy anyway
can't believe that guy saw my box I'm kind of annoyed about
that.
I'm kind of annoyed you saw my box.
I'm kind of annoyed by that.
Meet...
Slow and steady.
Don't move.
We're all still...
Oh, gosh, you scared me.
Snake, I unlocked the cargo door for you.
Right where I can see you.
They're gonna see you.
They're gonna find you out with that pretty tush of yours.
What do you mean by that?
I showed you my box, please respond.
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
I think we can avoid this guy.
Yeah, nice.
Oh, he's gonna see me now though, is he?
No, he went the other way.
Yeah, we're all good.
But there's another guy around here.
Where is he?
There's a guy up there.
Isn't there another guy?
Oh, the one tank is gone, so...
It's only just the one guy, right?
Okay, never mind.
And then we go in here, and there's a guy.
I have to be careful, though.
He's asleep.
Okay.
Guys, I always die here.
I'm scared.
I always die here.
But I want the suppressor.
Stealthy choke.
Stealthy.
I'm assuming you didn't mean to let them see your box.
You really didn't know I'm sorry.
Society turtle.
What are you talking about?
You got this boss?
Okay.
I'm preparing myself.
I'm going in for the hug.
Okay.
I'm being a little creep.
Yeah!
We'll wait for it.
Yeah.
Time to go fight.
Some other stuff.
Mew!
Be careful, Snake.
That airlock is set with infrared sensors.
You probably can't see them with your naked eyes, but there
are infrared beams coming out of that wall.
Touch any one of them, and the doors will seal off, and the
place will be flooded with poison gas.
Poison gas!
Somehow you've got to get through without setting off those
sensors.
Okay, why'd you take off the mask?
I don't know.
Maybe so we can hear her better.
Who knows?
Okay.
Rash.
Oh, nope.
Do I have to... Do I have to equip it?
I can't remember.
Do I have to, like...
There we go.
Nice.
Okay.
Um, so, just so I don't forget that.
And then, okay.
Cigarettes.
Oh my god.
Maybe I should use a ration.
I'm scared.
Oh, it's not going down.
So bad.
If we notice it going...
Oh my god, please, please, please, snake.
I can't see.
I can't see the one in front of me.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Alright.
Come on.
Up.
Okay.
And down.
Yay!
Try calling.
Hi Marrow.
I got through.
Be careful, Snake.
That airlock is set with infrared sensors in Alaska.
I did it, Colonel.
It looks like the place is protected by infrared sensors.
I didn't know a box is a euphemism.
Or who?
Then what do you mean?
It's a box.
It's a box!
Trust your instincts as a soldier.
As a gamer!
Yeah!
Snake, that room is set with infrared sensors.
You should be able to see them if you had some smoke Oh,
cigarette smoke or something You would suggest that wouldn't
you, Nostasia These are smokeless cigarettes You mean those
cigarettes that are designed to cut down on secondary
smoking Oh, well, don't worry If you blow the smoke in the
direction of the infrared sensors You should be able to see
them That was a good idea of bringing the cigarettes But,
uh, don't smoke too much cigarettes make you weak in mind
and body they are built for you she doesn't have a cigarette
she has a lollipop obviously i don't know i don't know why
i'm saving uh i just want to hear her voice
oh complete snake like shakespeare said knots had all spent
for our desire is got without content basically it means
that your desire can get you into trouble if you're not
careful i'm always careful don't get too greedy or you might
be sorry be careful snake see she's telling me not to go for
the for the goggles you guys i don't need it
Hong Mei Ling no no no no no
I didn't get a mind detector Wait, where do you get the mine
detector at?
Uh-oh.
Or is it not yet?
No, it is now, right?
What?
Yeah, we'll just crawl.
We're fine, guys.
We're fine.
There's, like, what, six of them here or something?
Who could that be?
Snake, be careful.
There are Claymore mines around there.
Use a mine detector.
I don't have that.
Who are you?
Just call me Deep Throat.
Deep Throat.
The informant from the Watergate scandal?
Never mind about that.
You're not using burst transmission.
Are you nearby?
Listen.
There's a tank in front of your position waiting to ambush
you.
So about them goggles.
Don't worry about it.
One of your fans.
He's one of my fans!
I'm gonna collect them right now.
They're around here.
I got them.
Hold on.
One?
Look how little life I have left, you guys.
It's so bad.
Maybe I should go back and get the mind detector, shouldn't
I?
Where is it at?
The goggles floor?
Second floor?
Okay.
Is there another ration over here?
I crawl because I don't remember.
Okay.
la la la la la la la la la la la la la la okay let's go back
uh the sensors are turned off now though right yeah they put
the ration and a claymore right next to each other so okay
but here i can save
mayling how can someone outside of this operation cut into
my codec i should ask talking about that guy calling himself
deep throat oh yeah we were monitoring from here Well, if
somebody knows your frequency, they can call you.
But the question is, how did he learn it?
It's top secret information.
Can you tell me where he called from?
I'm sorry.
We have a leak!
We have a rat!
Somewhere on the base.
Safe.
We've got a rat here!
I'm gonna just, you know what, I will do a new file.
It's fine, though.
Be careful, Snake.
Deep throat being a wisp.
140, 66 for an integral bonus.
140, 66?
Press cancel button to exit.
Music frequencies.
No way!
Oh my god!
It's so cool!
I'll be honest, though.
I don't remember the Metal Gear 2 theme.
I don't think I would have recognized it if you guys haven't
told me.
Because I don't really the only song I remember unless I
like heard it again.
I think because it's like not it's like what's it called?
I think because it's like a not from the game.
But I mostly remember just theme of Tara.
But um But yeah.
Thanks for this little Easter egg dude.
Thank you.
Okay, let's go back and get the mine detector.
Oh, I should also call everybody, hold on.
Oh, Canyon.
That was really cool though.
Snake, you'll have to go through the minefield to advance.
Oh, thanks.
Okay, thanks for your wisdom.
Master.
Master, does the name Deep Throat mean anything to you?
Oh boy.
Deep Throat?
That's what they call me at the club.
You mean the guy from Watergate?
Have you seen Kojima Snatcher or Policenauts?
I know them.
I have not played them.
I have not spoiled myself on them either.
Because I intend on playing them.
Yes.
I have no idea who that could be.
I see.
No idea.
Hey, Meryl, do you know Deep Throat or, uh, is that
harassment if I ask her that?
The place is mine.
Well, if you use it, use a mine detector you'll be able to
see the mines displayed on your radar okay if you need a
mine detector there should be one on the second floor of the
tank hanger she even tells me
nistasha it is just like baker said we are facing increasing
danger from stored nuclear materials you see there are three
elements necessary in the manufacturer of nuclear weapons
off topic
We call her and she's just like, something's going on.
Everyone's talking about, like, sniper while Wolf, and
she'll be like, nuclear materials are harming everything.
Shit.
Sorry, I breathed wrong.
What was I saying?
I don't remember.
Anyway, sorry.
it's a really really good lollipop so i breathe wrong you
know when you like breathe wrong and you're like half
swallow your spit wrong that's what just happened to me i
don't need i don't need the things though anymore right i
don't need the cigarettes oh no i do and do i do i do oh
goodness gracious good thing i good thing good thing i did
it oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god
Dang it, I really should have gone all the way over there
then.
I feel silly not having gone.
Do you think we can take this guy out?
Let's attempt.
Clean.
Oh, I'll take... Oh, never mind.
Is there a... Wait, is there anything under here?
Nope.
Okay.
It's truly the other side that I have to worry about,
though.
Oh,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
It's the other side that always freaks me out more.
But at least we don't have some guy downstairs being like.
Being like, what was that noise?
When they hear me walking across?
You can shoot the other guy with your sound.
Oh my gosh, I think you're right.
Wait, can I shoot him from here?
Can I shoot him from here?
This may be far.
What about now?
He's gonna see me.
me though.
Where is he?
Oh, he's all the way over there.
I think you can from that range.
Okay.
Is he gonna see me?
Okay, we'll see if he can see my box first.
Just a box!
Just a box.
He doesn't come over here, though, right?
Oh, he does, he does, he does.
Does he continue over here?
I think I'm going to try.
Oh, no.
Oh, my goodness.
I didn't get him.
Got him.
There we go.
Oh.
Oh, perfect, perfect.
Yippee!
I love killing!
Is there anything over there?
I can't remember.
It's probably not worth the risk.
Run away!
And we're free to run as freely as we want.
I enjoy the killing!
I love killing!
Kill, kill, kill, kill, kill!
Kill.
All you need is kill.
Kill, kill, kill, kill, kill.
Worst cameras in the world, they can't see even two feet in
front of them.
Adding more ghosts.
Run!
Is there anything else in here?
Now that I have free rein, I'm just gonna like...
We can go anywhere we want, baby.
Do I have enough grenades?
I got 12.
Okay.
I killed that guy in there even.
Continue onwards.
I couldn't tell.
Okay, this one's fast.
Okay, there we go.
Good, good, good.
This one's slow.
Sometimes it's hard to tell which is when...
Okay, this one is in front of me.
Okay.
Yippee!
Where's your thermal goggles?
I'll get them when I get them!
Good thing there are no radios in this.
Oh my gosh, it's such a blessing.
That's why I'm afraid for...
for, uh...
MGS2.
Yoink!
I can't remember.
Do I have to be...
behind it?
I'm just paranoid.
And...
Yoink!
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna check this side too.
Nothing here.
Okay.
And...
Now you can be in front if you're crawling.
Okay, cool.
I can never remember.
There is one that you can't be in front of it, right?
Or am I going crazy?
Yoink!
Yay!
More claymores!
And that should be all of them.
Okay.
Wait, there's nothing here, right?
Whoa!
I have such a bad habit of, like, stopping two steps before
the thing is supposed to occur.
I'm just five!
Okay, that's it.
That's it.
He's going to say it.
Snakes don't belong in Alaska.
Yeah!
I will not let you pass.
Send him a message.
Whoa!
Watch out, Snake.
He's so cool.
I love that line.
That's right.
You belong on the ground.
Vulcan Raven!
You should crawl on the ground like the snake you are.
So, let's fight.
Ah, I gotta get close.
I gotta get close.
Oh, shit.
Don't laugh at me.
I'm a Vulcan right now.
Come on.
Don't laugh at me.
I'm doing my best, okay?
I'm just a little snake.
Oh, my God.
How am I supposed to get close to him?
Oh, the chaps.
I think I'm okay.
Yeah!
Invincibility for arms!
Ba-da-ba-ba!
Oh my god, it wasn't soon enough!
Oh my gosh, no.
Did I
get it?
Ouch!
Ouch, y'all.
Oink,
y 'all.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Ouch, y'all, y'all, y'all.
Oh, come on.
That should have worked.
Don't run over me, please.
Yoink!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I said don't laugh at me, but like, oh
my, if I die to this, it'll be pretty funny.
I'm not gonna lie.
This fight is so dumb.
Oh, I
literally, oh, I love this part.
Oh, wait, no, I think I'm thinking of Twin Snakes, just
kidding.
Wasn't it three waves?
Guess not.
thinks it was well boss i hope you are happy there he goes
he got the car he sounds so disappointed wise not to
underestimate him he got the car did you think of him he is
just as you said in battle he is as if possessed by a ghost
much like you i would expect no less you see I told you so
but I will kill you so general Ivan I hear he took your hand
I hope you are happy shame in the language of the sue people
sue means snake soon it is known as an animal to be feared
well snake is mine now when I meet him next I'll take
special care of him not yet My...
We and I will meet again in battle.
Oh yes we will.
Yes, the raven on my head.
It thirsts for blood.
Haha!
Wait, I'm gonna go...
Yippee!
Oh!
Defeat the M1 tank!
Yay!
And let's get this rational over here.
In this building, we cannot use weapons!
Wow.
But I want to go back out there and get some stuff.
They don't install the cameras and stuff immediately, right?
Oh.
Level 3 car!
Let's go!
Call people.
I will, thank you.
But I will after we do this.
Okay, good.
I'm just gonna have the mine equipped, mine detector
equipped just in case.
I don't remember if there actually were any rations around
here, but...
Oh.
Yes.
Thank goodness.
Wait, I want to see that view.
Wow, so cool!
So cool, so cool.
It's so cinematic.
Can you finish off the Raven guy now?
I think he flew away.
I think he's like...
Gone, gone.
Oh.
Can I take over the tank?
I wonder.
That'd be pretty...
Pretty nifty.
I'm just charging to the nuclear warhead building in my
tank.
Newly acquired tank.
No worries.
Album cover?
Truly!
It is really like an album cover, right?
You're pretty good at this game?
You think so?
No, stop it.
Don't get my hopes up.
Just wait until MGS2, I promise.
Actually, no.
Wait until...
Psycho Mantis.
Wait until Psycho Mantis and then see if I'm good at this
game anymore.
now we can hold three rations yeah wait we had one the whole
time did i accidentally unequip it is that what happened am
i a silly goose am i a silly willy did i accidentally oh my
god can i like hide careful you absolutely must not use
weapons in that area a silly ghost i've already programmed
the nano machine so that he won't be able to what what are
you talking about have you forgotten gravy yeah there's lots
of boxes piled up here but are they all warheads they're all
dismantled warheads they just leave them here it's like
president baker said totally careless wait they're working
on a limited budget they try to put on a pretty face for the
media but this is the grim reality of it but nastasha knows
lots more I have no, like, protective anything.
All of the warheads in those boxes have had their detonation
mechanisms removed, so there's no fear of them exploding.
But, like...
But if the warheads are broken, they might leak plutonium,
and that would be a serious problem.
I'm gonna be... I'm gonna grow a second arm.
Never use your weapon on that floor.
Maybe even a third arm!
Who knows?
Okay, hold on.
Let me get in my box and go over here for a second.
Oh, okay, there he is.
You see, they get protective stuff, but not me.
Don't move Just a box Just a box Thanks Farrelly
You send the thing What have you got there a cardboard box?
Oh, I forgot to do this code at that Hold on.
We'll skip through it.
We did it earlier in case you're like why did you skip it?
They already did it everywhere.
Snake, you've got to rescue Dr. Emmerich, the Metal Gear
Engineer.
The Metal Gear Engineer!
He's got a fun ring to it.
Snake, never use your weapon on that floor.
I'm not gonna listen to you.
What can I do for you, Snake?
Second floor basement.
Why is everybody in the second floor basement?
Snake, in China, they say.
You must cross the river before you tell the crocodile he
has bad bread.
Do you know what that means?
It means that the wise man avoids danger first.
Use your brain to avoid traps and stay away from the enemy.
A cardboard box.
Oh, we heard this one too.
Sorry.
Okay.
What's with the box?
NBD.
Smick, that is a nuclear warhead storage area.
I must never use a nuclear warhead.
Yes, but their detonation mechanisms have been removed.
So I don't have to worry about this island turning into a
pile of smoking rubble.
No, but if the casing is damaged, they may be leaking
nuclear materials.
Please, make sure you do not use your gun around there.
Um, I'm more concerned about my body.
Like, if it's leaking nuclear materials, am I going to be
okay?
I am exposed!
Excuse me!
box huh oh we did this one sorry I forgot that we're gonna
get the cardboard box a bajillion times in war a split
second can mean the difference between victory and defeat
don't ever hesitate okay the slower you react the greater
the chance that you'll be beaten thank you master thank you
master thank you a cardboard box I heard stories from my
uncle but I always thought he was pulling my leg I've got no
comment okay Wow thanks I guess very insightful deep throat
do you have anything to say about my cardboard box I thought
you were one of my fans I thought you would like my box I
thought you said you were one of my Bands!
Should I...
I was stuck on the wall?
Wait.
Oh, there he is.
He comes down and around.
Wait for him to go around.
Showed you my box, please respond.
No, don't respond.
Don't look...
Don't look in my direction.
Don't even notice...
Just a box.
Continue on your merry way.
Where's the guy upstairs?
Oh gosh, this is difficult.
Oh god, I can't see it all.
There we go.
I think I just gotta go.
This guy doesn't come down the stairs, alright?
Oh, okay.
Turn around.
Say there, you're good?
Thank you.
Like I said, I couldn't remember if he came downstairs or
not.
And he stops somewhere.
And then he goes to the left.
Yes.
Books!
Oh, wait, I gotta go to...
Wait, I gotta go to B2 so that...
and I can be like, oh my god!
Choo!
Thank you!
I started saying meido-minto, like side-o-chesto, and I
can't stop.
Yeah, we gotta go here so we can be like, oh my god, it's
gas!
We gotta get the Nikita missile!
Nikita missile time.
Gosh, the music in here is so awesome.
Ha!
Damn.
Ooh!
Danger, danger.
Leading on Otakon's wall is fine.
Oh yes, we should do that.
And I'm gonna knock on it.
Oh my gosh, we're gonna get that scene.
Ah, hold on!
I can't breathe!
Cardo!
Oh, deep throat!
That place is filled with gas.
Also, the floor is electrified.
high voltage switch.
It really...
It really didn't want Otacon getting out.
I can't reach it.
Use a remote controlled missile.
Okay!
I gotta let me out so I can breathe!
So we have to go...
First, we gotta talk to him.
Hey!
I can't wait for that scene with Liquid when he goes Okay,
let's call everybody and they are gonna tell me to go back
all the way to the To the that other basement B2 basement
For the time being, let's trust what Deep Throat told us Use
a remote controlled missile to destroy the switchboard in
the northwest section of the warhead storage building second
floor basement make sure your remote controlled missile
doesn't get shot down by those gun cameras okay master the
backtrack that inner voice that warns you in danger is
nearby you can't learn that in training you gotta have
survived a few firefights seen a few friends blown away
could i have just gone in wait should i could i have just
gone and got it and then done the cutscene and already had
the Nikita missile.
Yes.
Yeah, once you have the level 3 card, it's okay.
We're doing it like we never played the game before.
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
We're...
I did that on my playthrough.
We're being accurate as if we have never played the game
before.
First playthrough role play.
Yeah, exactly.
The intended path.
Turn around?
Turn around.
Oh, nope.
This is for the authentic first-timer experience.
Experience.
Yeah!
Now
and then I get a little bit lonely and you're never coming
around.
Turn around Every now and then I get a little bit tired
Listening to the sound of my teeth Turn around Every now and
then I get a little bit something The best of all the years
have gone by Turn around Every now and then I get a little
bit terrified And then I see the look in the right Turn
around For right eyes Every now and then I get a little bit
tired I fall off turn around Bright eyes Every now and then
I fall apart And I need you now tonight And I need you more
than ever And if you only hold me tight We'll be holding on
forever And you'll only be making it right Cause you'll
never be wrong
U.S.
nuclear warheads and wastes have never been left neglected,
with very few exceptions.
Oh.
Cool.
Anyway, enjoy.
Thanks for the tip.
You're pretty good.
Huey.
Hi, Huey.
Wait, so now it's turned off, though, right?
And the other tank is gone, right?
Unless, wait.
Wait.
The tank that I just shot down was the one that they used.
Never mind.
Thanks for the super chat.
Here we go.
It's turned off now, though, right?
Please say yes.
No!
Why?
This is so cruel.
At least it's, like, kind of easy to get to the...
To the, uh, elevator from here.
But I gotta get the thermal...
Oh, I know.
I gotta get the thermal goggles.
Someone's gonna go get the thermal goggles.
Where is that guy?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, oh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh.
He can't see me, though, right?
I'm kind of pretty good at that.
Thanks for the super chat!
There's a super...
Sorry, I don't mean to pause it like that.
There's a super neat show called Over the Garden.
Why?
I think you'd really like.
We should watch it later this fall.
I love that.
I love that show.
Thanks for the super chat!
We should watch it.
Mint singing got me melting like Tuscargoo.
Stop!
I think you need level four?
Okay, never mind.
Can anybody attest to that?
Oh wait.
I always press that instead of...
Can I see it from here?
It is four!
You can see it from down here.
This is four, I think.
It says Four It says four It says four You saved me, you
really saved me Whoever said that Okay
Second floor basement And don't get caught in here
Wait Unless you get it at the beginning of the game before
the DARPA chief.
How do you get it?
Is it actually a glitch or is it just like a something way
to get it?
Guys, I don't remember at all which one had the Nikita.
Remember earlier I was like, we should look at these and
memorize which one is what?
No, it's the front middle one.
Because the front, the top left one was the PSG.
Top middle was the Nikita.
Which means we're We're gonna have to come all the way back
here.
The door is four, but open before that.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
The thermal goggles door is open if you enter the hangar
from the top vent.
Oh, I never go through the top vent.
That's why I don't know.
I never go through the top vent.
I'm just gonna wait for these guys to leave.
Can they hear me?
Can they hear me footsteps?
Wait a second.
Okay, we're gonna go this way instead.
Don't drop and die.
That was close.
That was really close.
Is this one?
I don't trust it.
Wait, this is the seafloor!
Where's the Nikita missiles then?
Wait, is B1 of the nuclear storage?
I thought it was in here!
Wait, I thought it was in here!
Why'd I come all the way back then?
I thought it was in the other building.
Wait.
It's in both.
Oh my god.
Oh, I misremember...
It's always the dang card levels that give me!
Are you kidding me?
You did the same in the Twin Cities!
It's always the card levels that give me!
No, so it's a level 4 card here!
Oh my god, hold on.
No way.
That's so funny.
It gets me every time.
First time playing!
Why don't you guys stop me from leaving the building then?
What?
Oh my gosh, I'm a silly goose.
Is it this one?
I can't remember.
La la la la la.
Ah!
You guys, we could do either one.
Gosh.
Don't scam me like that.
Look at it.
You guys!
Oh my gosh!
I thought so!
I'm not crazy!
Sometimes.
All the time.
Come on, elevator.
You were just here.
No one used it.
But we'll have to come back here again anyway, because we
have to get the PSG.
Saving.
Hello
everybody, I'm just a simple...
Oh, I almost went thinking that it was...
Dunzo.
Wait, I can't see it.
Oh, there it is, okay.
Nice and slow.
Fast.
Thinking you kept those cigarettes in your stomach!
Stummy, Siggy's.
Your stamina, physique must be in top condition to actually
walk around a cardboard box like that.
Right?
Like, you are crouched the whole time.
Like, it's actually quite impressive the way that, like...
Gosh, I wish these would respawn.
It's impressive the way Snake can actually run with it.
Like, I mean, that's why he's like the...
Oh, I just realized... Sorry, I just noticed my cursor.
That's why he's like the greatest... He's the legend!
He's a legend!
That's why his butt's so big.
The cardboard box is like bopping up and down against his
fat ass as he runs.
My fat ass, Mei Ling.
My cake is just too thick.
It's clapping.
How's it going, Snake?
Have you gotten used to using the radar yet?
I think so.
Yeah, it's a great system.
Not only can I read the topography, but I can monitor the
movement of the bad guys, too.
So awesome.
Pretty convenient, huh?
It also makes it easy for us to see everything that you're
doing.
You're watching everything?
Of course.
If you were my boyfriend, you'd never be able to cheat on
me.
Being monitored 24 hours a day.
that'd be like hell don't think of it trying to do huh at
least you'd never get lost that you don't want people to
monitor you for huh what are you trying what are you doing
for the time being let's trust what deep throat told us i am
use a remote controlled missile yeah warhead store oh oh no
it says to destroy the switchboard in the northwest section
of the warhead okay okay i was like wait a second the
warhead storage building second floor basement no that's
where That's where we were.
That's where it's at, you guys.
I lived near a nuclear facility as a kid and recently found
out they kept all the enriched uranium in a six-year-old
wooden warehouse!
You're Spider-Man.
I think.
Probably.
They say that there are 500,000 nuclear engineers in the
world.
How can you watch Golden Girls if someone's watching?
After the end of the Cold War, the demands for nuclear
engineers dropped precipitously.
In the Eastern Bloc countries, in particular, there is a
tremendous brain drain.
That's me.
Every day, I have a brain drain.
And each year, more and more nuclear engineers go to work
for the highest bidder.
True brain drain.
When you're trying to hide, avoid places that look like the
enemy might search.
Think about how your enemy is going to move.
and then sneak in there doesn't matter how smart you are
just use your head out there you tell me i'm dumb master
what do you mean by that deep throat no i don't know anyone
who calls himself that i see i wonder why he's trying to
help you i have no idea a trap could be but for the time
being i'll have to trust him
There we go.
I gotta get the other box in there too.
It's in there, right?
But most crucially for stealth, box.
Where's the other guy?
There's a guy up there.
Where's the guy that loops around?
Oh, there he is.
Hello.
Oh gosh, the sound of their footsteps is just true ASMR.
meant like feat asmr confirmed oh no i love feat asmr like
uh have you guys ever listened to the the like the way they
walk in barbie movies it's so crisp it's so like it's just
it just really hits the spot it's so like i said it's just
so like
Wrong button.
There we go.
I swear if you look up like...
If you look up like Barbie movie...
Footstep sounds.
I'm sure there's a video of it.
It's like... It's a popular thing that people talk about.
I promise.
The Barbie...
The Barbie feet are what everybody's on about.
I swear.
Took huge psychic damage yesterday when someone pointed out
That after you make a joke, Doki often repeats the joke and
compared it to Solid Snake.
No way, really?
Nah.
Also, Nano, I saw that you started clipping the twin snakes.
Do you plan on doing all the Metal Gear games?
If so, I'm really sorry.
I'm really, really some solid bird.
What a terrible name.
Solid bird.
All right, hold on.
Before we...
Oh, shoot.
I only have eight.
Okay, press the X button.
And then I just let her rip.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
I forgot there's no first person.
Shit!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Now I remember.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, don't get caught.
Yippee!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Easy peasy.
I remember when I couldn't ever even find that.
I'd be like, where the hell is it?
Can I go in here?
Yes.
Yippee!
And the gas mask is in this one?
Nope.
The gas mask is in this one.
Should I chaff?
Okay, hold on.
I think I should chaff though, right?
Okay.
Probably.
Chaff it up, bro.
Let's chaff it up.
Chaff it up.
I
don't even know if I can go into the other ones.
Oh, come on.
I don't want to waste all my traps, Braun.
How does the electronic door open with the trap?
You're so right.
And the key to myself is good, good, good, good, good, good,
good, good.
You know what?
Let's just call it here.
Ow!
Oh god, run, run, run!
Oh my gosh, my mask!
Okay!
Um, I didn't get the other ration, though.
You can blow up the cameras with Nikita.
You can.
Can you go upwards?
Excited for Delta?
I am super, super excited.
So, so, so excited.
Oh, come on.
It's cheap.
Oh, Stinger.
I was gonna say, I don't think you can do it with the
Nikita, right?
Uh, wait.
What does that say?
How's Lab?
Keep out?
Wait, I've never noticed that before!
That's so funny.
How's Lab, keep out!
And now for one of my favorite scenes in the whole game.
One of my favorite scenes in the whole whole game oh wait i
need a i love this part so much oh i love this part so much
okay sorry i'm getting excited it
looks like they were cut by some type of blade
VL.
It is me.
Oh,
so cool.
Oh my god, it's so freaky.
It's a ghost.
A brief moment when it turns into a horror game.
I know, it's so awesome.
It's that ninja.
Don't...
Each of these bodies have a unique camera angle if you
crouch next to them.
Oh, I'm not sure.
Oh!
Oh my god, you're right!
What?
No way!
That's so cool!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, oh my god!
What?
oh is he still alive are you okay man i think i can save you
wait one of them still alive him this guy's still alive you
good you're good man i'm crawling i'll give you CPR come
here
oh yeah he's even a little red dot oh sorry don't don't use
tongue when doing He is done when...
He
is done when applying CPR, everybody.
Oh my gosh, it's so cool.
Wow!
This is so awesome.
Oh my gosh, it's so freaky.
This is so cool.
Wow, thank you for teaching me about this.
I had no idea.
Oh my god, the way he died.
So sad.
It's so cool.
Oh, not that guy, though.
He's not special.
He doesn't get his own.
Oh, there he is.
There it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think a specific character Bloodstain later in the game
does this as well.
Same with Johnny's naked body after he...
Ah.
Oh, black void.
Okay.
fight that I struggle with sometimes but um but hopefully
we've been doing okay on the boss fight so far in fact I
think the way of camouflage who are you each time I've died
has been by something stupid what what are you talking about
Oh, Otacon.
Oh, what next?
Peepie pants, man.
Peepie their pants.
You're that ninja.
I've been waiting for you, Snake.
Who are you?
Peepie, boy.
Neither enemy nor friend.
I am back from a world where such words are meaningless.
Ignore the voice actor.
I've removed all obstacles.
Now, if you and I were battles, to the death what do you
want what do you want i've waited a long time for this day
now i want to enjoy the moment what's with these guys here
it is here it is it's like one of my japanese anime yeah
i've come for another world to do bad with you what is it
revenge oh my god it is nothing trivial is revenge please
not a fight to the death with you only a lack in my soul
find respite isn't it respite i will kill you or you will
kill me respite it makes no difference i don't Fine.
We can watch from inside there.
I need that, man.
Keep your hands off him.
God, sorry.
Now, make me feel it.
Hurt me more, Snake.
That's good, Snake.
Now we can fight as warriors.
Bujo Minto.
It is the basis of all combat.
I got you.
Hand-to-hand combat.
Where are you?
Come here.
Oh my god.
Ouch.
I'm gonna die.
Oh, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, snake.
Oh my god.
He's got invincibility!
He's going crazy.
He's doing Cirque du Soleil flips over here.
Oh!
Ouch!
Oh my god.
He hits.
He packs a punch.
this fight is way i mean all the fights are way easier in
twin snakes but this fight is way oh my gosh oh my gosh oh
my gosh he really hits hard he hits really hard
when does it oh i thought i wasn't gonna make that one come
here come here
There it is.
Okay.
That's good, Snake.
Hurt me more.
Oh, I'm not good at this part.
Uh, oh.
Okay, never mind.
We know where he is.
Run!
Oh gosh, I'm on the other side of the room.
Oh, don't come after me!
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming!
Ah!
I got you, I got you first.
Oh, I got him first.
I got him first.
I think I hear him?
I think I hear him.
No, I don't.
Uh, oh.
Nice, nice, and nice, and nice.
I don't I don't know where you are where are you oh
can I keep punching him I think I keep punching him the
whole time where is he oh he's still walking oh shit oh shit
I forgot he did this okay hurt me more hurt me more I forgot
he teleported okay Come on, come on.
I couldn't predict.
Oh gosh.
Wait, did I already lose a...
Oh, yikes.
Hat me more.
Nice, nice, nice.
That's it.
I remember that punch.
Remember Snake?
The feel of battle you.
The clashing of bone and with you.
Punch me more!
Do your thing.
Punch, punch, kick!
Ah!
Oh shoot.
I can shoot him now, right?
Where'd he go?
One, one, one, dad, dad.
One, one, dad, dad.
Where'd he go?
Oh, he's over here destroying all the chairs.
One, one, dad, dad.
Yay!
I felt that snake.
Do you remember me now?
Can't be.
First try, yeah!
I've gotten a little bit better at this game.
What?
Not again.
What's happening?
Uh, dropped plot line is what's happening, Snake.
I am losing myself.
So essentially, for people, if you don't know, is it over?
Um, there was going to be like a thing with...
I can't exactly remember what it was about, but like, his
whole freakouts were going to be a whole subplot.
and they had they had to drop it so um but but i guess the
scenes stayed in yeah they had to cut it out gray fox
colonel that ninja is gray fox no doubt about it ridiculous
the hurt people should know he died in zanzibar snake's
voice there he should have died but he didn't what makes me
so before i joined foxhound's medical staff they were using
a soldier for the gene therapy experiments i never heard
that good after it happened right after you retired david
hater's amazing predecessor dr clark was in charge dr clark
yes he started the gene therapy project dr clark where is he
now dead he was killed in an explosion in his lab two years
ago so what about this soldier apparently for their test
subject they decided to use the body of a soldier who was
recovered after the fall of zanzibar let's and that was gray
fox but he was dead yes but they revived him they fitted him
with the prototype exoskeleton and kept him drugged for four
years while they experimented on him like a play thing
today's genome soldiers were born from those experiments
that's the sickest thing i ever heard they used him to test
all sorts of gene therapy techniques i feel like this is an
underrated soundtrack why didn't you tell us about this
sooner you know track from the osu that's really good is
that the only reason Naomi so sick what happened to gray fox
after that the record says he died in the explosion I see
but even if that ninja is gray fox the question is why why
from what I could tell he didn't know who he was are you
saying that he's just a mindless robot no I'm not sure but
he seems intent on fighting me he remembered he remembered
again you snake so you'll fight ago i don't want to spoil
myself i'd rather not finish but maybe that's what he wants
but if you don't have time you can always come back and
watch me finish for you thanks for hanging around thank you
oh my god here he goes how long are you gonna stay in there
are you one of them get out of there your baby i always work
alone starting to get a are you an otaku too come on get out
he doesn't Yeah, get out.
I'm starting to get a caffeine headache, I think, from the
coffee.
I didn't sleep much last night, which is why I got a coffee.
I fell asleep at 5 a.m., you guys.
Hal Emmerich, right?
Yeah!
You know me?
I heard about you from Merrill.
Oh, so you're here to rescue me.
Christopher Fritz?
But no, there's something that I've got to do first.
They change his name.
Well, at least you're not one of them.
Oh, you sad, pathetic guy.
I'm okay.
I just twisted my ankle a little bit trying to get away.
Well, if that's all, it's nothing to worry about.
It was always Fritz in this.
I guess I never...
I want to ask you something.
I never...
I need information about Metal Gear.
It's Germa.
Oh, my God.
Metal Gear?
That clip of him.
Yeah.
What's Metal Gear really designed for?
Some of the VAs use aliases.
It's a mobile TMD.
It's designed to shoot down nuclear missiles.
Only for defensive purposes, of course.
Of course!
Oh!
I already know that Metal Gear is nothing but a
nuclear-equipped, walking death, Mofio.
Don't bully the nerd!
Nuclear?
What are you talking about?
The terrorists are planning to use Metal Gear to launch a
nuclear missile.
Oh my god.
You didn't know?
They're gonna put a dismantled warhead into Metal Gear's TMD
missile module?
Wrong.
From the beginning, the purpose of this exercise was to test
Metal Gear's nuclear launch capability, dummy nuclear
warhead the terrorists are just continuing the work you
started no you're wrong I heard it directly from your boss
Baker little baby no a nuclear missile on Rex so you really
didn't know no all the armament was built by a separate
department and the president personally supervised the final
assembly of the main unit president Baker yeah I was never
told exactly what they arm directs with.
I only know it's equipped with a Vulcan cannon, a laser, and
a railgun.
A railgun!
Kenneth no!
Kenneth yes!
A railgun, you said.
Yeah.
It uses magnets to fire bullets at extremely high
velocities.
The technology was originally developed for the SDI system
and later scrapped.
He even installed a PPI gun on it!
Are you an otaku?
Yes, I am!
The railgun is on railgun.
Rex is right on.
Metal Gear's main function is to launch nuclear missiles.
You sure you're not forgetting something?
Rex is so cute.
It's true that Metal Gear has a missile module on his back
that can carry up to eight missiles, but are you saying it
was originally meant to carry nuclear missiles?
They turned the Cepheia filter up to 80 on this.
Cute?
Yes!
Rex is so cute.
Ray is cuter.
But that's not all I think.
And I stand by that trap.
If Metal Gear fired only standard nuclear missiles, then
they should already have all the practical data they need.
Oh my god.
there.
No.
Look it up.
Could it be?
Metal Gear's co-developer, Rivermore National Labs, was
working on a new type of nuclear weapon.
They were using Nova and NIF laser nuclear fusion testing
equipment and supercomputers.
So they developed a new type of nuclear weapon in a VR
testing lab, huh?
Yes, but you can't use virtual data on a battlefield.
They would need actual launch data these are some of the
supercomputers if you link these you can test everything in
a virtual environment but it's all just theoretical so this
exercise was designed to test the real thing ray is a bit
cooler what did our president do if the terrorists launched
that thing sassy the fifth snake is sassy snake damn he's
standing like a jojo stand i'm such a fool No!
It's all my fault.
Otacon, it's not your fault.
Little baby.
You're just a little baby.
The truth is, my grandfather was part of the Manhattan
Project.
Oh gosh.
He suffered with the guilt for the rest of his life.
And my father, he was born on August 6th, 1945.
The day of the Hiroshima bomb.
I'm sorry.
not funny but it's just a sense of humor all right it's just
so goofy oh my god he's three generations of americ men he
was born stupid we must have the curse of nuclear weapons
written into our dna
i used to think that i could use science to help mankind
this guy just wanted to make the one who wound up getting
used was me this guy wanted to make gun guns using science
to help mankind gotta feel sorry about how he got played i
know that's enough crying pull yourself together where is
metal gear every game basically keeping it every game snake
is having to tell oticon to stop crying and pull himself
together play the i'm nuclear song from rex is in the
underground maintenance base where is that north of the
communications tower but it's a long way there the emergency
override system for the detonation code is there too yeah in
the maintenance base control room you'd better hurry if they
were planning a launch from the start then their ballistic
program is probably finished and since they haven't called
for me in a few hours they must not need me in other words
they must be ready to launch Merrill's got the detonation
code override keys we'll link up with her if we can't
override the launch we'll have to destroy Rex he fell when
he didn't go toward genetics to create cat girls I mean I'll
show you the way look at this poor sad guy you'll just slow
me down you'll need me if You're gonna destroy Rex.
Hanukkah, you smell like piss!
Everyone will smell you from a mile away, please.
Use your brain.
I created Rex.
It's my right.
My duty to destroy him.
No.
If you get a chance, try to escape.
When the coast is clear, I'll contact you by codec.
How am I supposed to escape from an island?
Swim!
Okay.
So what then?
I want you to hide somewhere and keep me informed.
You know this place well, don't you?
Of course I do.
And don't worry.
I've got this.
Can I have this?
Can I have that?
It's the same stealth technology as the ninja.
Foxhound was going to use him, but with this, I'll be fine.
Bad leg at all.
Can I have that?
I want Merrill to watch after you, too.
Merrill, the engineer is okay.
That's a relief.
I want you to look after him.
Do you hear it?
Where are you now?
Very close.
There she is.
Over there!
Oh no!
Damn, they've spotted me!
Meryl, what happened?
Something's wrong.
Did you hear something?
Wasn't that some kind of music?
Yeah, it was.
What did she look like?
Oh.
She... she was wearing the same green uniform as the
terrorists.
Here we go.
Autocon being a little perv.
Yeah, what else?
A disguise?
She has such a cute way of walking.
She kind of wiggles her behind.
really looking.
Well, she's got a very cute behind.
Way of walking, huh?
Oh, yeah.
Two, thank you.
If she's disguised as the enemy, you'll have to contact her
when she's alone, huh?
I see, I see.
There's only one place where we can be sure she's by
herself.
Where's that?
Codec during after bosses.
Yes, thank you.
Don't forget, don't, don't feel like, um, don't, don't feel,
don't hesitate to remind me because I will forget because I
just kind of like go through game since I've played it so oh
oh IBS IBS IBS IBS you're not in pain oh my god that made my
controller feel okay nothing bothering you why are you so
wrong getting all friendly all of a sudden why are you so
close I'm glad you're okay you're strange I'm a little
nervous everyone else I've saved suddenly dies your bad luck
your bad luck I love this interaction Otakon it stands for
Otakon it stands for otaku convention and otaku's a guy like
me who likes Japan Amation.
Japan was the first country to successfully call me
MintoCon.
I also like Japan Amation.
And Japanese cartoons played some part in that?
They did.
Yeah!
I didn't get into science to make nuclear weapons, you know.
This is police knots, right?
I became a scientist because I wanted to make robots like
the ones in the Japanese anime.
Yeah!
I like how they capitalize anime.
That just sounds like a childish excuse to me.
Yeah!
It's short for a mint convention.
You have to take responsibility.
Science has always thrived on war.
Greatest weapons of mass destruction were created by
scientists who wanted to be famous.
But that's all over now.
They're not cartoons.
Snack.
I won't take part in murder anymore.
Whatever.
All I want from you is information.
Sure.
I know everything about this whole base.
I don't care about your idea.
and your morals.
Also, with this stealth camouflage, I can sneak in and out
of the armory.
If this game was made today, he would be talking about me
too.
If you need ammo or rations, just tell me and I'll bring
them to you.
I'm on frequency 141.12.
Otakon will be a fan of Pecora.
That's why he didn't create cat girls.
He wants bunny girls, you guys!
At least not stream windmints.
Sometime.
Whenever I get around to it.
Yay!
Defeat Ninja!
Yubi!
Yubi, yubi, yubi, yubi, yubi, yubi.
He wanted mech girls?
Based.
Based, based, based.
Take all the things we can get.
Hoo-ha.
I wish there was more ration.
Okay.
It's not a phase, it's a lifestyle.
So true.
Oh, PlayStation.
But I actually, I don't know if you guys noticed.
I'm playing, um, well, you guys saw that I'm playing the
Master Collection, but I'm playing it on PC.
NIF was first announced in 95 and planned to finish building
in 05, but budgeting issues, push it back to 09.
NIF was ready by 05, like at MGS.
Ignition still wouldn't happen until 2017.
Wow.
okay now we go kind of looks like a Saturn it is a
PlayStation though right I mean that would make sense
because this was for the this was for the PlayStation 1 but
it does kind of I could see the Saturn right I could see it
it does kind of look like one it's so thick I had a
PlayStation one but it was the thin one.
The Saturn was black.
Well that looked darker, right?
It looked like a darker color.
So I can see how you would mistake it.
Oh.
Wait, hold on.
Oh my gosh.
Bless you, Kojima, for your awesome camera angles, your
cinematic.
God, it looks so Oh, it looks so...
Oh, it's so scary.
Oh, my gosh.
Like, you come in, imagine.
You haven't walked into this room yet.
You walk in for the first time.
And...
And you, like, instead of...
Instead of, like, seeing what's going on, and you're, like,
pressed against the door.
Oh, it's so good!
So awesome.
Dash Mario School.
He really likes movies.
He dies.
Yes, he dies.
He really likes movies.
You think I can... well, I don't want to use all my trap
grenades right now.
I want the ration though.
This one right there.
I want it!
What is in that box?
We're in a key to missiles, baby.
Or ammo?
To the first floor.
And we gotta go see.
A cute little behind.
I'm wondering if I have time to...
Well...
I don't know if I have time to beat Psycho Mantis.
It really depends on how much I game.
And I don't trust myself.
I didn't make it so far.
But...
far, but I did take an hour to watch some cutscenes.
To watch the briefings.
I think I'll save Psychomantis for next week.
I think maybe.
Oh, here comes the guy from the potty.
Hello.
Good boy.
Psycho-Mintus.
Yeah, that was me.
Oh, oh my god.
That's so funny.
Oh, he's coming back.
He's got to pee.
Sorry.
Oh, I got a ration.
Lucky day.
Oh, oh shit.
Oh.
I've never heard her do the huh I've never heard her do that
oh my gosh we found her immediately that's crazy hello
lady's room that was so easy nothing is nothing is
Oh!
No move!
She bested me.
Again.
That's the second time I've been able to sneak up on the
legendary Solid Snake.
You're Merrill?
There's no way you could pass for a man for long.
What do you mean?
Hey, men aren't allowed in here.
I had no idea you were so feminine.
This is no time to try and hit on you, Snake.
I love it.
Just flirts with anything that moves.
Besides, it's a waste of time.
When I joined up, they gave me psychotherapy to destroy my
interest in men.
Oh yeah, and that totally worked.
Yeah, it totally works against Solid Snake.
After all, I was disguised as a genome soldier.
So why'd you change?
You'd be a lot better off dressed like one of them.
I got tired of disguising myself.
This girl look, please.
The truth is, the uniform smelled like blood.
The foxhound tattoo.
What's that mark?
Huh?
Oh, this?
It's a paint tattoo.
It's not real.
I was a fan of Foxhound way back, and guys like you and my
uncle were in it.
Snake is different.
None of that gene therapy like there is today.
You guys were real heroes.
There are no heroes in war.
All the heroes I know are either dead or in prison, one or
the other.
But Snake, you're a hero, aren't you?
I'm just a man who's good at what he does, killing.
There's no winning or losing for a mercenary.
The only winners in war are the people.
That's right, and you fight for the people.
I've never fought for anyone but myself.
I've got no purpose in life, no ultimate goal.
Come on.
It's only when I'm cheating death on the battlefield.
The only time I feel truly alive.
Seeing other people die makes you feel alive, huh?
You love war and don't want it to stop?
Is it the same with all great soldiers throughout history?
Why didn't you contact me?
My coat on the hip.
He's so sassy.
Shouldn't you just be happy we met up like this?
How did you recognize me in disguise?
Lady so there's something you like about me, huh?
Yeah.
You've got a great butt.
God.
He's so honest first It's my eyes now.
It's my butt.
Oh, what's next on the battlefield?
You never think about what's next.
Oh my god Snake you you How are the negotiations going?
No progress.
I don't know So it's all up to you, huh?
Living in the moment somebody's got to stop them from
launching a nuclear missile There are two ways.
Either we destroy Metal Gear or we override the detonation
code.
The music's so awesome.
You got the card keys from Baker?
Card keys.
Girl, you have pockets!
Where are the others?
There should be three keys.
You have pockets!
This is all a god.
Where could the other two be?
I have no idea, but they must be somewhere.
If we can't find them, we'll have no choice but to destroy
Metal Gear.
Okay, she's only got one at a time.
Metal Gear is in an underground maintenance base to the
north.
Take me too.
I know this place better than you do.
She really loves the membership.
Thank you.
You don't have enough battle experience.
I won't slow you down.
I promise.
And what if you do?
She says until we have to backtrack for...
I don't like to waste bullets.
She's like, I won't slow you down until we have to backtrack
all the way back to the...
One building.
You know, I don't use makeup the way other women do.
Pick me now.
I hardly ever look at myself in the mirror.
You hate makeup.
I've always despised that kind of woman.
i always dreamed of becoming a soldier but i was wrong i'm
not like other girls it wasn't really my dream my father he
was killed in action when i was younger you wanted to follow
in your father's footsteps not really i thought that if i
became a soldier i could understand him better so are you a
soldier yet wow i thought i was until today but now i
understand she she truth is i was just afraid of looking at
myself afraid of having to make my own decisions She had one
day.
One day here and she was like, oh, I'm not a superhero.
I want to know who I am, what I'm capable of.
I want to know why I've lived the way I've lived until now.
I want to know.
Take a good look.
You won't get another chance for a while.
You should wash your face too while you're at it.
This isn't a training exercise.
Our lives are riding on this.
There are no heroes or heroines.
If you lose, you're worm food.
Yeah.
Where?
Is that FAMIS functional?
Unfortunately, it's out of ammo.
Where'd you get that desert eagle?
I found it in the armory.
It's a 50 caliber action express.
There was a SOCOM pistol too, but I chose this.
We got the leftovers.
So I got a leftover, huh?
Isn't that gun a little big for a girl?
Hey!
I can handle it.
She's more comfortable with it than a bra.
Use my 45.
Listen, I've used a gun like this since I was eight years
old.
I'm more comfortable with it than I am with a bra.
Yeah!
If we're going to go to the north, we'll have to go through
the commander's room on this floor.
The overland route is blocked by glaciers.
We're both girly pops, okay?
That's how I knew she was going to say that.
This card will open it.
It was inside the pocket of the uniform I was wearing.
Looks like he must have been guarding someplace important.
You have pockets!
Okay, let's go.
better than you she's just i'll be point man follow me
follow me she's just she's just showing off how perky her
her chest is you know that's strange there's no guard and
the music stopped what happened to the music i'll keep a
lookout i'll make sure you're ready i can keep up the music
what
stun grenade good thing we didn't oh whoops a good thing we
didn't go in here earlier right attempt to even get anything
out of here because I was like oh the guys are just gonna
disappear before we uh before we move on anyway what's under
here la la la oh I think I I'm just looking for rations at
this point are you gonna make Meryl blush of course I'm
gonna make Meryl blush of course
Night vision goggles!
You all can shut up.
You all can shut the hell up.
We got the night vision goggles.
You can all shut up.
We can all be quiet about the night vision goggles.
We do not need anything further.
Cardboard box B!
Oh.
This is, uh... This one has written... Heliport.
Heliport.
Go to the heliport.
Would you rather be...
Actually, how do you pronounce that?
It's like Yuki.
Would you rather be friends with Paz, Quiet, Merrill, the
boss, or Eva?
Um...
Probably...
Sunny.
And then this is probably to the nuclear warhead building.
As if I had to guess.
But thermal goggles.
but but but but thermal goggles my beloved thermal goggles
what are they playing video game all right let's go stare at
her let's go stare at a pretty lady i love staring at a
pretty face
what what is it oh my god she started to get red immediately
did you see that what are you staring at i can see it so
clearly I never used to be able to see it that well, but now
I can see it like Come on, Snake Happening Come on, Snake
Don't stare at me like that Yeah
What are you doing?
We've got to get a move on What are you doing?
Silly boy
What?
What is it?
Is this as red as it goes or?
I think I remember her getting quite red.
What are you staring at?
Stop.
Shy girl.
Come on, Snake.
She's so red.
She's folding.
I know.
All it takes is for Snake to, like, look at her.
Don't stare at me like that.
Staking nothing, and she just folds, man.
He is so powerful.
What are you doing?
We've got to get a move.
I had no idea, Meryl, was this much of a baddie.
No wonder I've seen so much fan art of her.
Oh, I know, right?
She's...
What?
What is it?
Okay.
Look at her, she's so red!
You're cute.
Why can't I go into the...
I need a card to go to the bathroom?
Snake, what are you doing?
Let's go to the commander's room.
The commander will see you now, Mr. Foxhound.
You would also fold if snake stared at you.
You're 100% correct.
I love this guy.
Oh my god, look at her.
What are you staring at?
She is a tomato over there.
My goodness.
Damn, dokey.
Okay, if I save...
Will I have to, like, find her again?
Or where will it...
You know what?
Let's go to another...
Can I go to another floor?
No, I can't.
Hmm.
If I say...
It won't let me switch floors.
Snake, let's hurry up and go to the commander's room.
Okay.
Do I have to do Psycho...
Can I do Psycho Mantis in 30 minutes?
It also...
Must have been said that you're a cute bot.
What?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
We're not talking about me.
It will load up after meeting her.
Oh, okay, great.
then I'm gonna let's do some codex first and then I'll
Colonel your niece is fine thank goodness We can't relax not
yet I know Snake she is quite a woman as commander of this
operation I can't ask you to watch after Merrill but talk
about me first don't talk about his family like that sending
my own flesh and blood to war she understands about duty I
know she does but what I want you planning to do to her What
was the real purpose of this military exercise?
I don't know.
Like I said, I'm nothing more than a middleman.
Is this transmission being monitored by the military?
Of course.
I'll explain afterwards.
All the world's a stage and we're merely players, right?
Yes.
But even players can influence the play.
I just hope we can prevent it from having a bad...
Stop!
Stop pointing at me!
So, for those who don't know, there is like...
There's an option to save the animals or kill the animals.
you can save Meryl or you could kill Meryl it's in a scene
um it's in a scene uh uh coming up ish like a little bit a
little ways away but um coming up after the next couple of
bosses um next two bosses but um if you save her and if you
kill her it's two different endings um I will be saving her
because it's the canon ending and since I'll be playing
through all the games um I want to do the canon ending so
that it matches with the timeline of what I'll be playing.
So that's my thought process with it.
Just like a Super Metroid.
Exactly.
What do you mean canon in quotes?
Well, but if you're interested in the other ending, we
totally did it in Twin Snakes, so you can go watch it there.
Master!
You managed to link up with Merrill.
Good.
So now you must have card keys that will override the
detonation code you should hurry the time limit is running
out okay master i'll do it for you i'll do it for you master
what do i call merrill no response come on pick up pick up
merrill she's like looking at me like hey let's get a move
on buddy
you found merrill
I forgot how to say hello.
Matara taught me how to say hello in Russian.
If I heard it, I would know it, I think.
Oh, Privyet!
Yes, Privyet!
Yeah!
I remember, I remember.
Well, because you guys typed it.
Oh, thank you for running this event and working towards
solving hyper cancer.
towards saving the animal.
Can I get a hype?
Can you mean to...
Stop it!
Okay, let's talk to me then.
It's a good thing you hooked up with Merrill.
Remember, with the sisters.
You should have seen the Colonel.
He doesn't like to let it show because he's the boss, but he
was so happy he could barely contain himself.
I'm glad to hear that.
Save.
Okay, guys.
Next week, we're starting with Psycho Mantis.
Oh, my goodness gracious.
I don't know if I will Endurance to the end.
I still have quite a ways away.
I'm not even, like, halfway through the game.
What would be halfway through the game?
Heindy, maybe.
Greetings from Germany.
Psycho Mantis is halfway maybe When it tells you to insert
disc too No no that's further That's further down I believe
Yeah Raven is near the end Yeah Raven is the last boss fight
Before Rex Sorry spoilers for people I'm just trying to
think i'm just trying to think god see you back in good form
good luck on mantis next week have fun watching doki thank
you yeah i just uh i have um like i said i didn't i didn't
sleep i went to bed at like 5 a.m i get i get um a delayed
jet lag so when i first come back from japan i'm usually
fine for the first couple of days and then after a couple of
days i can't go to sleep until 4 or 5 a.m But I still wake
up at 10 a.m.
So, um, I mean, it's still five hours of sleep, which isn't
bad.
But if I'm recovering from sick, I don't want to push it too
much.
So, um, but, uh, yeah, I guess maybe the Hein D would be
halfway probably.
Thank you.
I wish this could go all night.
Well, maybe next time we will go all night.
I might just get so into it.
I might just be like, I've got to, I'm going to go forever.
So, yeah.
But, yeah, have fun watching.
If anybody's watching Doki, have fun watching her tonight.
And also, the debuts, the next Hollow Live debuts, the
Justice debuts, I wanted to be watching.
I didn't realize, I thought they were Saturday, Sunday.
I didn't realize it was yesterday.
But we had already made our schedule before it was
announced.
So I was just like, afterwards, I was like, oop, I didn't
realize.
So, whoopsie.
But yeah, so exciting weekend.
Thanks for kicking off Metal Gear with me.
Hopefully I didn't do so poorly.
Putting my incentive to school 666, right?
Okay, we'll see.
I might have to, like, we might, I mean, I don't think the
game is out yet, but we also might need some time to grow
additional brain cells anyway.
Spank, thanks for the 10 gift, and thank you, thank you.
But yeah, so.
Always fun watching people play games they love.
Yeah, maybe next week we might endurance it.
Who knows?
I might be tired because I have a pretty busy week next
week.
i'll talk about that later and yeah metal gear i'm nervous
about psychomantis but i handled the other bosses pretty
well so maybe i'll maybe my gamer skills have improved
thanks to master miller use your instincts as a gamer so you
know maybe i don't know maybe maybe metal gear rex won't
take me so long.
I seem to have a brief recollection of taking the longest
time with Rex.
But we'll see.
I think I've improved as a gamer a little bit.
Your skills have improved.
Yippee!
You're quite fast, though.
Yeah, I think so.
Otsuminta everybody!
Thank you!
I'm gonna go eat because I'm hungry, hungry, hungry.
I'm a hungry ghost and you guys should as well and enjoy the
rest of your Saturday!
Or if it's Sunday for you, get some rest.
What are you doing still awake?
Otsuminta!
Eat it a-shai-go-shin-jama!
Ojo-sama!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
See you guys tomorrow for more doom!
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for letting me indulge in my brain rot a little bit
more.
Bye-bye.
I just realized I didn't let Mei Ling finish like speaking.
But all she said was talk to you later, Snake.
She didn't give me a proverb or anything.
I think she hates me.
Oh, Mei Ling hates me.
She hates me.
Mei Ling hates me, you guys.
Really hates me.
Oh my god, she hates me.
Oh, she hates me.